Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to ther face a moment longer. A judge? A soldier? A prince? Someone used to great responsibility and responsible in his authority. Someone too conscientious. A worrier. Perhaps a perfectionist. Someone too who suffered ill health as a child.
Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to ther face a moment longer. A judge? A soldier? A prince? Someone used to great responsibility and responsible in his authority. Someone too conscientious. A worrier. Perhaps a perfectionist. Someone too who suffered ill health as a child.|||感谢收听《历史余音》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 ther face a moment longer. A judge? A soldier? A prince? Someone used to great responsibility and responsible in his authority. Someone too conscientious. A worrier. Perhaps a perfectionist. Someone too who suffered ill health as a child.
He had that incommunicable, that indescribable look that childhood suffering leaves behind it. He turned the portrait over to look for a caption. On the back was printed, Richard III. Now that is Josephine Tay's novel The Daughter of Time, published in 1951. It's often described as one of the greatest whodunits ever written. It's the book that effectively kick-started the kind of Ricardian romance with Richard III, and it is by far the most celebrated attempt
He had that incommunicable, that indescribable look that childhood suffering leaves behind it. He turned the portrait over to look for a caption. On the back was printed, Richard III. Now that is Josephine Tay's novel The Daughter of Time, published in 1951. It's often described as one of the greatest whodunits ever written. It's the book that effectively kick-started the kind of Ricardian romance with Richard III, and it is by far the most celebrated attempt|||他身上有一种无法言传、难以名状的神情，那是童年痛苦留下的痕迹。他把画像翻过来寻找说明文字。背面印着：理查三世。这就是约瑟芬·铁伊于1951年出版的小说《时间的女儿》。它经常被誉为有史以来最伟大的推理小说之一。正是这本书实际上开启了对理查三世的某种“理查迷恋”，它也是迄今为止最著名的尝试
to solve the mystery of the princes in the Tower. Tom Holland until now now because now the rest is history we'll tread in josephine tay's footsteps and we will solve the mystery won't we well yes i i'm sure we'll come to this when we we look at um how people have understood the mystery of the princes in the tower but that that thing in josephine's that Richard looks a kind of kind man. He's very kind. So the head of the, the lady who discovered Richard III
to solve the mystery of the princes in the Tower. Tom Holland until now now because now the rest is history we'll tread in josephine tay's footsteps and we will solve the mystery won't we well yes i i'm sure we'll come to this when we we look at um how people have understood the mystery of the princes in the tower but that that thing in josephine's that Richard looks a kind of kind man. He's very kind. So the head of the, the lady who discovered Richard III|||去解开塔中王子之谜。汤姆·霍兰，直到现在——因为现在《历史余音》将跟随约瑟芬·铁伊的脚步，我们要解开这个谜团，不是吗？嗯，是的，我确信当我们探讨人们如何理解塔中王子之谜时，我们会谈到这一点，但约瑟芬书中的那个观点是，理查看起来是个善良的人。他非常善良。所以，这位女士——发现了理查三世的
in that car park in Leicester, Philippa Langley, she famously said, didn't she, when she saw a portrait of Richard III, I think she says it in the documentary, is that the face of a tyrant? Such a kind face. Yes.
in that car park in Leicester, Philippa Langley, she famously said, didn't she, when she saw a portrait of Richard III, I think she says it in the documentary, is that the face of a tyrant? Such a kind face. Yes.|||莱斯特那个停车场里的人，菲利帕·兰利，她曾有一句名言，不是吗？当她看到理查三世的画像时——我想她在纪录片里说过——这就是暴君的脸吗？多么善良的一张脸。是的。
I have to say when you look, because it's reconstruction isn't it based on the that's right the body the skull that was found i think when you look at him it was terrifying looks actually rather like lawrence olivier in there yes he does actually well that's because they've given him olivier's wig though haven't they anyway we'll come on to all that um but uh welcome back to the second half of um our episode on the princes in the tower and dominic in the first half um basically he's only just become king edward the fifth yeah so we should pick up on the 9th of april uh 1483 shouldn't we so edward the fourth has died and he's left two sons, Edward 12, Richard 9. Richard, he's with
I have to say when you look, because it's reconstruction isn't it based on the that's right the body the skull that was found i think when you look at him it was terrifying looks actually rather like lawrence olivier in there yes he does actually well that's because they've given him olivier's wig though haven't they anyway we'll come on to all that um but uh welcome back to the second half of um our episode on the princes in the tower and dominic in the first half um basically he's only just become king edward the fifth yeah so we should pick up on the 9th of april uh 1483 shouldn't we so edward the fourth has died and he's left two sons, Edward 12, Richard 9. Richard, he's with|||我必须说，当你看着——因为这是根据发现的遗体和头骨进行的面部复原，对吧？——我觉得当你看着他时，太惊人了，实际上看起来有点像里面的劳伦斯·奥利弗。是的，他确实有点像。嗯，那是因为他们给他戴了奥利弗的假发，不是吗？不管怎样，我们会谈到所有这些。但是，欢迎回到我们关于“塔中王子”节目的下半部分。多米尼克，在前半部分里，基本上爱德华五世才刚成为国王，对吧？所以我们应该从1483年4月9日开始接下去，对吧？爱德华四世去世了，留下两个儿子：12岁的爱德华，9岁的理查。理查和
his mother, isn't he, in London? Yeah, in London. But Edward is in Ludlow with his uncle, Anthony Woodville Lord Rivers. And then he has another uncle, Richard of Gloucester, who is basically the boss of the North, who's up in the North. So the moment
his mother, isn't he, in London? Yeah, in London. But Edward is in Ludlow with his uncle, Anthony Woodville Lord Rivers. And then he has another uncle, Richard of Gloucester, who is basically the boss of the North, who's up in the North. So the moment|||他的母亲在伦敦，对吧？是的，在伦敦。但爱德华在勒德洛，和他的舅舅、里弗斯伯爵安东尼·伍德维尔在一起。然后他还有另一个叔叔，格洛斯特的理查，基本上是北方的老大，在北方。所以当
Edward IV dies, there is a degree of boss of the north yeah who's up in the north so the moment middle of castle edward the fourth dies there is a degree of well there isn't necessarily uncertainty straight away what happens is a council meets doesn't it and they agree fine edward the fourth has died we'll have the coronation of edward the fifth on the fourth of may but the issue is he's too young to rule in his own right at the age of 12. So obviously there's some uncertainty about who's actually going to basically... So basically it's four years, isn't there? Yeah.
Edward IV dies, there is a degree of boss of the north yeah who's up in the north so the moment middle of castle edward the fourth dies there is a degree of well there isn't necessarily uncertainty straight away what happens is a council meets doesn't it and they agree fine edward the fourth has died we'll have the coronation of edward the fifth on the fourth of may but the issue is he's too young to rule in his own right at the age of 12. So obviously there's some uncertainty about who's actually going to basically... So basically it's four years, isn't there? Yeah.|||爱德华四世去世时，某种程度上……北方老大，是的，他在北方。所以当爱德华四世去世的那一刻，某种程度上——嗯，倒不一定马上就有不确定性。发生的事情是，一个议会开会了，不是吗？他们同意：好吧，爱德华四世已经去世，我们将在5月4日举行爱德华五世的加冕典礼。但问题是，他才12岁，太年轻了，无法亲政。所以很显然，关于到底谁将……基本上这就是四年，对吧？是的。
So not long, but long enough, I suppose, to entrench your networks and to use the power of patronage. Who's going to control the machine between now and then? That's the question. Well, there are two things on there. Who's going to control the machine between now and then that's the question well there are two things on there who's going to control the machine and who is going to have control access to the young king because those are two slightly different issues okay so we we have two questions which i think go together very well one from joe johnson was there any scenario in which the woodvilles or
So not long, but long enough, I suppose, to entrench your networks and to use the power of patronage. Who's going to control the machine between now and then? That's the question. Well, there are two things on there. Who's going to control the machine between now and then that's the question well there are two things on there who's going to control the machine and who is going to have control access to the young king because those are two slightly different issues okay so we we have two questions which i think go together very well one from joe johnson was there any scenario in which the woodvilles or|||所以时间不长，但我想，也足够长到巩固你的人脉网络并利用恩庇权力了。从现在到那个时候，谁来控制这个国家机器？这才是问题所在。嗯，这里有两个方面。从现在到那时谁来控制国家机器，这就是问题所在，嗯，这里有两个方面：谁来控制国家机器，以及谁能控制和接触年轻的国王，因为这是两个略有不同的问题。好的，所以我们有两个问题，我认为它们配合得很好。一个来自乔·约翰逊：是否存在任何一种情况，伍德维尔家族或者
the council could have outmaneuvered richard to protect the prince's succession or was richard just too powerful and the prince's fate was sealed as soon as edward the fourth died and robert elliott did richard have his eye on the crown from the moment edward the fourth died or was it only when he realized edward the fifth would never forgive him so um you know massive spoiler alert there yeah of course everyone listening to this episode will know that um richard ends up taking the crown. Yeah. So those two. The fifth vanishes into the tower.
the council could have outmaneuvered richard to protect the prince's succession or was richard just too powerful and the prince's fate was sealed as soon as edward the fourth died and robert elliott did richard have his eye on the crown from the moment edward the fourth died or was it only when he realized edward the fifth would never forgive him so um you know massive spoiler alert there yeah of course everyone listening to this episode will know that um richard ends up taking the crown. Yeah. So those two. The fifth vanishes into the tower.|||议会能够智胜理查以保护王子的继承权？还是说理查实在太强大，以至于从爱德华四世去世的那一刻起，王子的命运就已经注定了？罗伯特·埃利奥特问：从爱德华四世去世的那一刻起，理查就盯上王位了吗？还是说，只有当他意识到爱德华五世永远不会原谅他时……所以，你知道，这里有个巨大的剧透。是的，当然，听到这一集的每个人都会知道，理查最终夺取了王位。是的。所以就是这两个问题。爱德华五世消失在了伦敦塔中。
But was it inevitable that was going to happen? Was Richard always planning to be to usurp the crown? That's that's basically the plot of Richard the third. Yeah. The plot of Richard the third. Richard is trying to get rid of everyone who stands in the way of him you know he he murders everybody uh and that clearly seems to i mean that's clearly not not the case but when edward iv dies does rich does the news that does richard think okay this
But was it inevitable that was going to happen? Was Richard always planning to be to usurp the crown? That's that's basically the plot of Richard the third. Yeah. The plot of Richard the third. Richard is trying to get rid of everyone who stands in the way of him you know he he murders everybody uh and that clearly seems to i mean that's clearly not not the case but when edward iv dies does rich does the news that does richard think okay this|||但这注定会发生吗？理查一直计划着篡夺王位吗？这基本上就是戏剧《理查三世》的剧情。是的，《理查三世》的剧情。理查试图除掉所有挡他路的人，你知道，他谋杀所有人，呃，这显然看起来——我的意思是，这显然不是事实。但当爱德华四世去世时，理查、这个消息……理查是否会想：好吧，这
is my chance to become king i would say no tom i would say absolutely no yeah i uh i think there's no evidence to suggest that richard is thinking of becoming king before his brother dies and i would now the interesting thing is that the common portrait of richard iii is the sort of the shakespeare portrait he's incredibly cunning and conniving and he's planning everything long in advance he's playing a very long game i don't think there's any evidence for that i think he is he's planning everything long in advance. He's playing a very long game. I don't think there's any evidence for that. I think he is... He's as caught short as everybody else. From the moment his brother dies,
is my chance to become king i would say no tom i would say absolutely no yeah i uh i think there's no evidence to suggest that richard is thinking of becoming king before his brother dies and i would now the interesting thing is that the common portrait of richard iii is the sort of the shakespeare portrait he's incredibly cunning and conniving and he's planning everything long in advance he's playing a very long game i don't think there's any evidence for that i think he is he's planning everything long in advance. He's playing a very long game. I don't think there's any evidence for that. I think he is... He's as caught short as everybody else. From the moment his brother dies,|||是我成为国王的机会？我会说不，汤姆，我会说绝对不会。是的，我——我认为没有任何证据表明理查在他哥哥去世前有当国王的想法。而现在，有趣的是，人们对理查三世的普遍画像就是莎士比亚笔下的那种形象：他极其狡猾奸诈，凡事都提前很久做长远规划，在下一盘很大的棋。我认为没有任何证据支持这一点。我认为他……他和其他人一样被打了个措手不及。从他哥哥去世的那一刻起，
he is scrambling as they all are to find their place in the new world. And he's constantly improvising. I think some of his biographers have pointed this out, that actually he doesn't seem to have a long-term strategy. He is constantly grasping for kind of short-term solutions, which often cause then problems of their own further down the line. So he'll make and break alliances, pick people up and drop them,
he is scrambling as they all are to find their place in the new world. And he's constantly improvising. I think some of his biographers have pointed this out, that actually he doesn't seem to have a long-term strategy. He is constantly grasping for kind of short-term solutions, which often cause then problems of their own further down the line. So he'll make and break alliances, pick people up and drop them,|||他和所有人一样，在焦头烂额地寻找自己在崭新局势中的位置。他一直在临机应变。我想他的一些传记作家已经指出这一点：实际上他似乎并没有什么长期战略。他总是在抓取一些短期的解决方案，而这些方案往往在以后会带来它们自己的问题。所以他会结盟又撕毁联盟，拉拢一些人又抛弃他们，
all of these kinds of things. However, there is kind of a warning from history, from the reign of Henry VI, who of course was even younger than Edward V. So he had to have a kind of protector. And that role was taken on by Humphrey, the Duke of Gloucester, who was the youngest brother of Henry V. And it doesn't end well for him. His wife gets accused of witchcraft. He gets kind of dragged down in scandal. He's chiefly remembered now for setting up a library in Oxford. So Richard knows that the role of protector is a treacherous one.
all of these kinds of things. However, there is kind of a warning from history, from the reign of Henry VI, who of course was even younger than Edward V. So he had to have a kind of protector. And that role was taken on by Humphrey, the Duke of Gloucester, who was the youngest brother of Henry V. And it doesn't end well for him. His wife gets accused of witchcraft. He gets kind of dragged down in scandal. He's chiefly remembered now for setting up a library in Oxford. So Richard knows that the role of protector is a treacherous one.|||诸如此类的事情。然而，历史上有过一个警示，来自亨利六世的统治时期——他当然比爱德华五世还要年轻，所以他必须有一个摄政王。这个角色由亨利五世的小弟、格洛斯特公爵汉弗莱担任。他的结局并不好。他的妻子被指控犯有巫术，他自己也陷入了丑闻之中。他现在最让人记住的事迹是在牛津建立了一座图书馆。所以理查知道，摄政王这个角色是个充满背叛风险的职位。
And it's all the more treacherous if there are kind of rival factions who hate you. So the question, isn't it? The Joe Johnson's question about could the woodvilles have outmaneuvered richard now maybe you'll disagree with me about this tom i don't know i would say yes there clearly is a scenario in which the woodvilles win the day and i would say that by not by looking backwards but by looking forwards as we did a little bit in the last episode so this is not massively dissimilar from the position when Henry VIII dies. He also has a very young heir in Edward VI who has a parvenu family around him, the Seymours.
And it's all the more treacherous if there are kind of rival factions who hate you. So the question, isn't it? The Joe Johnson's question about could the woodvilles have outmaneuvered richard now maybe you'll disagree with me about this tom i don't know i would say yes there clearly is a scenario in which the woodvilles win the day and i would say that by not by looking backwards but by looking forwards as we did a little bit in the last episode so this is not massively dissimilar from the position when Henry VIII dies. He also has a very young heir in Edward VI who has a parvenu family around him, the Seymours.|||如果还有恨你的敌对派系，那就更危险了。所以这个问题，对吧？乔·约翰逊关于“伍德维尔家族能否智胜理查”的问题——也许你会在这点上反驳我，汤姆，我不知道。我会说：是的，显然存在一种伍德维尔家族获胜的情况。而且我认为，不是通过回顾过去，而是通过展望未来，正如我们在上一集里稍微做过的那样——所以这跟亨利八世去世时的情景并没有太大区别。他也有一个非常年轻的继承人爱德华六世，周围环绕着暴发户家族西摩家族。
Now, what happens with Henry VIII and that succession? He takes longer to die. So the Seymours have lots of time to get all their forces lined up. They also have a little bit of a coup before Henry VIII dies to get rid of their factional rival, the Duke of Norfolk and stuff. So as soon as Henry VIII dies, they move into position, their troops seal off roads, they take possession of the young king, they sort it all out, and basically, you know, it's fine. They win the day.
Now, what happens with Henry VIII and that succession? He takes longer to die. So the Seymours have lots of time to get all their forces lined up. They also have a little bit of a coup before Henry VIII dies to get rid of their factional rival, the Duke of Norfolk and stuff. So as soon as Henry VIII dies, they move into position, their troops seal off roads, they take possession of the young king, they sort it all out, and basically, you know, it's fine. They win the day.|||那么，亨利八世和那场王位继承发生了什么？他死得比较慢。所以西摩家族有充足的时间让所有部队就位。在亨利八世去世前，他们还发动了一场小型政变，除掉了派系对手诺福克公爵等人。所以一等亨利八世咽气，他们就迅速就位，军队封锁道路，控制了小国王，把一切都安排妥当，基本上，你知道的，一切顺利。他们赢了。
Now, the Woodvilles don't do that i think partly because they don't have time but also arguably because they are less ruthless they are insufficiently ruthless i would say i think they don't identify richard's as a they don't identify two people one is richard and the other is a man called Hastings. Yes. So I think a further reason why they can't coordinate is that the two key Woodvilles, so Elizabeth, the Queen, and Antony, her brother, are separate. The Queen is in London and Antony Lord Rivers is in Ludlow. Yeah. It's a big problem that he's in Ludlow.
Now, the Woodvilles don't do that i think partly because they don't have time but also arguably because they are less ruthless they are insufficiently ruthless i would say i think they don't identify richard's as a they don't identify two people one is richard and the other is a man called Hastings. Yes. So I think a further reason why they can't coordinate is that the two key Woodvilles, so Elizabeth, the Queen, and Antony, her brother, are separate. The Queen is in London and Antony Lord Rivers is in Ludlow. Yeah. It's a big problem that he's in Ludlow.|||而伍德维尔家族没有这样做，我认为部分原因是因为他们没有时间，但也可以说是因为他们不够冷酷，我说他们不够冷酷。我认为他们没有把理查视作……他们没有认清两个人：一个是理查，另一个是个名叫黑斯廷斯的人。是的。所以我觉得他们无法协调的另一个原因是，伍德维尔家族的两个关键人物——王后伊丽莎白和她的兄弟安东尼是分开的。王后在伦敦，而安东尼·里弗斯勋爵在勒德洛。是的。他在勒德洛是个大问题。
So you mentioned Hastings um yeah he'd been a chamberlain sorry i didn't finish my sentence hastings is is so that the the big we've talked about the rivalries with between the woodvilles and and richard um which obviously the kind of titanic ones but there are there are other factions within the yorkist court as well and hastings is a key player he's been a kind of loyal supporter of Edward IV right the way through. In fact, he kind of takes a bribe from Elizabeth Woodville and Hastings do kind of try and arrive at an accommodation. Obviously, they can't do it with reference to Richard because he's up in the north. But they kind of arrive at an agreement that all the people who come into London should have small retinues. So that you're not getting large armies kind of
So you mentioned Hastings um yeah he'd been a chamberlain sorry i didn't finish my sentence hastings is is so that the the big we've talked about the rivalries with between the woodvilles and and richard um which obviously the kind of titanic ones but there are there are other factions within the yorkist court as well and hastings is a key player he's been a kind of loyal supporter of Edward IV right the way through. In fact, he kind of takes a bribe from Elizabeth Woodville and Hastings do kind of try and arrive at an accommodation. Obviously, they can't do it with reference to Richard because he's up in the north. But they kind of arrive at an agreement that all the people who come into London should have small retinues. So that you're not getting large armies kind of|||所以你提到了黑斯廷斯，呃，是的，他曾担任内侍。抱歉我没说完上一句，黑斯廷斯是……所以我们谈到了伍德维尔家族和理查之间的竞争，这显然是那种巨头间的争斗，但在约克王朝宫廷内部还有其他派系，黑斯廷斯就是个关键人物。他一直是爱德华四世坚定的忠实支持者。事实上，他收受了伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的某种贿赂，黑斯廷斯和她确实试图达成某种妥协。显然，他们无法在涉及理查的情况下做到这一点，因为他在北方。但他们达成了一项协议，即所有进入伦敦的人都应该只带少量的随从。这样你就不会看到大批军队
congregating because they don't want another outbreak of the wars of the roses kind of scenario where people pitch up with little armies exactly and so that that shows that um that Hastings and and uh the Woodvilles are kind of trying to arrive at an accommodation um there's kind of famous scene in Shakespeare's's play where edward's on his deathbed and he um he he obliges all the various factions to kind of kiss and make up i think that's true actually tom isn't that i think it is true there's chronic chronicle evidence yeah yeah and just to go back to the factions with the question we had last episode is this edward the fourth's great sort of downfall is that his failing as a I mean, my answer to that would be,
congregating because they don't want another outbreak of the wars of the roses kind of scenario where people pitch up with little armies exactly and so that that shows that um that Hastings and and uh the Woodvilles are kind of trying to arrive at an accommodation um there's kind of famous scene in Shakespeare's's play where edward's on his deathbed and he um he he obliges all the various factions to kind of kiss and make up i think that's true actually tom isn't that i think it is true there's chronic chronicle evidence yeah yeah and just to go back to the factions with the question we had last episode is this edward the fourth's great sort of downfall is that his failing as a I mean, my answer to that would be,|||聚集起来，因为他们不希望再次爆发类似玫瑰战争那样的局面，即各方带着小军队蜂拥而至。完全如此。这表明黑斯廷斯和伍德维尔家族正试图达成某种妥协。莎士比亚的戏剧中有一个著名的场景，爱德华在病榻上，他强迫各个派系握手言和。汤姆，我觉得这其实是真的，难道不是吗？我认为这是真的，有编年史证据支持。是的，是的。回到关于派系的问题，这是我们上一集讨论过的问题：这是爱德华四世最大的垮台原因吗？这是他作为……我的回答是：
remember the factions are always going to be there. There's always going to be all this competition for lands, for estates, for offices, that they're kind of often starting at a very, very local level. You see it in the past and letters and things, this famous kind of medieval source. So it's inevitable there's going to be a degree of rivalry. The question is, I suppose, what they all have to calculate is,
remember the factions are always going to be there. There's always going to be all this competition for lands, for estates, for offices, that they're kind of often starting at a very, very local level. You see it in the past and letters and things, this famous kind of medieval source. So it's inevitable there's going to be a degree of rivalry. The question is, I suppose, what they all have to calculate is,|||记住，派系永远都会存在。永远都会有对土地、庄园、官职的各种争夺，而且它们往往从非常非常地方性的层面开始。你可以在《帕斯顿书信集》等著名中世纪史料中看到这一点。因此，一定程度的竞争是不可避免的。我想，问题在于他们所有人必须权衡的是：
are we all going, is there anybody with an ulterior motive? When people talk about compromise, do they mean it? If they don't mean it, should I strike first or should I do nothing? Well, you could absolutely say, did you ever play the game Kingmaker? Oh, no, I know the game you mean. It's a sensational board game, which kind of revolves around all these kinds of tensions. You know, who do you make alliances with? Who do you kill?
are we all going, is there anybody with an ulterior motive? When people talk about compromise, do they mean it? If they don't mean it, should I strike first or should I do nothing? Well, you could absolutely say, did you ever play the game Kingmaker? Oh, no, I know the game you mean. It's a sensational board game, which kind of revolves around all these kinds of tensions. You know, who do you make alliances with? Who do you kill?|||我们所有人都在前进吗？有没有人怀有不可告人的目的？当人们谈论妥协时，他们是认真的吗？如果他们不是认真的，我是应该先发制人，还是什么都不做？嗯，你完全可以说——你玩过《拥立者》（Kingmaker）这个游戏吗？哦，不，我知道你指的是哪个游戏。那是一款轰动的桌游，主要围绕着所有这些紧张局势展开。你知道的，你跟谁结盟？你杀谁？
All this kind of stuff. And you can see why, you know, this such dramatic material for Shakespeare and then the influence that those plays have had on mafia dramas or whatever. I mean, it is a very tense scenario. But so essentially what's agreed is that Elizabeth Woodville and Hastings in London are trying to arrive at accommodation. There's the council as well in London, and they're also part of it.
All this kind of stuff. And you can see why, you know, this such dramatic material for Shakespeare and then the influence that those plays have had on mafia dramas or whatever. I mean, it is a very tense scenario. But so essentially what's agreed is that Elizabeth Woodville and Hastings in London are trying to arrive at accommodation. There's the council as well in London, and they're also part of it.|||诸如此类的事情。你能理解为什么这对莎士比亚来说是极好的戏剧素材，以及这些戏剧对黑帮剧或其他类型作品产生了怎样的影响。我的意思是，这是一个非常紧张的局面。但本质上，大家达成的共识是，在伦敦的伊丽莎白·伍德维尔和黑斯廷斯正试图达成妥协。伦敦的议会也在其中，他们也是其中的一部分。
The question is what's going to happen to the young king's two uncles. And they agree that they will rendezvous at Northampton. That's right. So Richard and Anthony Woodville. Anthony Woodville is bringing Edward with him, and Richard is coming south, and they will meet in Northampton. Now, Richard is also going to meet another person who we haven't mentioned at all, who is the Duke of Buckingham.
The question is what's going to happen to the young king's two uncles. And they agree that they will rendezvous at Northampton. That's right. So Richard and Anthony Woodville. Anthony Woodville is bringing Edward with him, and Richard is coming south, and they will meet in Northampton. Now, Richard is also going to meet another person who we haven't mentioned at all, who is the Duke of Buckingham.|||问题是，年轻国王的两个叔叔将如何处置。他们同意在北安普顿会合。没错。所以是理查和安东尼·伍德维尔。安东尼·伍德维尔带着爱德华同行，理查则从南方北上，他们将在北安普顿会面。现在，理查还将去见另一个人，我们之前完全没提到过，那就是白金汉公爵。
And Buckingham had been Edward IV's ward. He's a landowner in the sort of in the Welsh marches he's got a big place at Brecon called Brecknock um he's a slightly disaffected figure yeah slightly on the fringes of the regime isn't he well he like the house of York and like the house of Lancaster is descended from Edward the third. Yeah. So here's a very, very tenuous, very tenuous claim. And he's married to Catherine Woodville, who is one of the queen sisters.
And Buckingham had been Edward IV's ward. He's a landowner in the sort of in the Welsh marches he's got a big place at Brecon called Brecknock um he's a slightly disaffected figure yeah slightly on the fringes of the regime isn't he well he like the house of York and like the house of Lancaster is descended from Edward the third. Yeah. So here's a very, very tenuous, very tenuous claim. And he's married to Catherine Woodville, who is one of the queen sisters.|||白金汉曾是爱德华四世的受监护人。他是威尔士边境一带的土地所有者，在布雷肯有一个叫布雷克诺克的大庄园，嗯，他是一个略有不满情绪的人物，对吧？有点处于政权边缘，不是吗？嗯，他和约克家族以及兰开斯特家族一样，都是爱德华三世的后代。是的。所以这里有一个非常非常微弱、非常微弱的王位继承权主张。而且他娶了凯瑟琳·伍德维尔，也就是王后的姐妹之一。
Yeah. So he's kind of part of the world, but he's slightly on the outside, but he's ambitious, isn't he? And he was brought up with Richard, wasn't he? Yeah.
Yeah. So he's kind of part of the world, but he's slightly on the outside, but he's ambitious, isn't he? And he was brought up with Richard, wasn't he? Yeah.|||是的。所以他算是圈内人，但又有点置身事外，不过他很有野心，对吧？而且他是和理查一起长大的，不是吗？是的。
So they know each other well. But he's never been a player particularly till now going back just got a quick question um to a quick moment to robert elliott's thing about richard is richard as he comes south is he thinking right i need to plan this to get my hands on the crown i would say no i would say i need to i need to get my hands on the king what he's thinking is he's been running the north he has all his people that he knows in the north and people who owe him loyalty and he he owes them his protection you know that's the way this works that's the way the system works so his guiding principle i think is how can i protect my own
So they know each other well. But he's never been a player particularly till now going back just got a quick question um to a quick moment to robert elliott's thing about richard is richard as he comes south is he thinking right i need to plan this to get my hands on the crown i would say no i would say i need to i need to get my hands on the king what he's thinking is he's been running the north he has all his people that he knows in the north and people who owe him loyalty and he he owes them his protection you know that's the way this works that's the way the system works so his guiding principle i think is how can i protect my own|||所以他们彼此很熟悉。但他直到现在一直算不上是个核心政治玩家。回到刚才罗伯特·埃利奥特关于理查的问题：理查在向南进发时，他是不是在想“好，我得策划一下来染指王位”？我会说不。我会说：“我需要——我需要控制国王。”他当时的想法是：他一直在管理北方，他在北方拥有所有熟悉的手下、以及那些效忠于他的人，而他有义务保护他们。你知道，事情就是这样运作的，体制就是这样运作的。所以他的指导原则，我认为是：我如何才能保护我自己的
position and make sure that i don't end up being killed and my people stripped of all their estates and my family thrown out in the cold. I think that's what's driving him. They're all driven as much, I think, by fear as they are by greed or ambition or any of those things. And I think there's no question as to what his answer to that question is, which to begin with is not to take the crown himself, but to take control of the young king. And we know that because of what happens, which is that on the 29th of April,
position and make sure that i don't end up being killed and my people stripped of all their estates and my family thrown out in the cold. I think that's what's driving him. They're all driven as much, I think, by fear as they are by greed or ambition or any of those things. And I think there's no question as to what his answer to that question is, which to begin with is not to take the crown himself, but to take control of the young king. And we know that because of what happens, which is that on the 29th of April,|||地位，并确保自己不会最终被杀，自己的人民不会被剥夺所有财产，我的家族不会被赶尽杀绝。我认为这才是驱动他的动力。我认为，他们所有人受到的恐惧驱动，和受贪婪、野心或任何其他东西驱动的程度一样多。对于那个问题，他的答案毫无疑问——起初不是自己夺取王位，而是控制年轻的国王。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为接下来发生的事情：在4月29日，
they all meet up at Stoney Stratford, which is just outside. Well, the Woodvilles are in Stoney Stratford, but this is British actually. And he's in Northampton, isn't he? And Richard is, and Buckingham arrives late. That's right. And Richard and Buckingham kind of plot.
they all meet up at Stoney Stratford, which is just outside. Well, the Woodvilles are in Stoney Stratford, but this is British actually. And he's in Northampton, isn't he? And Richard is, and Buckingham arrives late. That's right. And Richard and Buckingham kind of plot.|||他们都在斯托尼斯特拉特福会合了，就在……嗯，伍德维尔家族在斯托尼斯特拉特福，但这其实是英国的……他在北安普顿，对吧？理查在……而白金汉迟到了。没错。理查和白金汉密谋了一番。
Well, so Richard's already met. So the Woodvilles, they've left Edward at Stoney Stratford with his retinue. They go into Northampton for a meeting with Richard. And apparently at that meeting, he has a very cheerful and merry face. So that all seems to go well. Buckingham arrives late. And then we know that Richard and Buckingham sit up late into the night talking.
Well, so Richard's already met. So the Woodvilles, they've left Edward at Stoney Stratford with his retinue. They go into Northampton for a meeting with Richard. And apparently at that meeting, he has a very cheerful and merry face. So that all seems to go well. Buckingham arrives late. And then we know that Richard and Buckingham sit up late into the night talking.|||所以，理查已经见过面了。伍德维尔家族把爱德华和他的随从留在了斯托尼斯特拉特福。他们前往北安普顿与理查会面。显然在那次会面上，他（理查）表现得非常高兴和快活。所以一切似乎都很顺利。白金汉迟到了。然后我们知道，理查和白金汉深夜畅谈。
And then the next morning, everything changes, doesn't it? So Anthony Woodville wakes up to find that his bed and breakfast, his Airbnb is surrounded. So too does Edward V's half-brother, Sir Richard Grey, the youngest son of Elizabeth Woodville before she married Edward IV. And they're arrested. And Richard and Buckingham go to see Edward V. And they say that Rivers was not just a traitor, but morally disreputable. And this is something that Richard is very, very keen on. He's very hostile to displays of vice and very, very keen on kind of playing the defender of morality.
And then the next morning, everything changes, doesn't it? So Anthony Woodville wakes up to find that his bed and breakfast, his Airbnb is surrounded. So too does Edward V's half-brother, Sir Richard Grey, the youngest son of Elizabeth Woodville before she married Edward IV. And they're arrested. And Richard and Buckingham go to see Edward V. And they say that Rivers was not just a traitor, but morally disreputable. And this is something that Richard is very, very keen on. He's very hostile to displays of vice and very, very keen on kind of playing the defender of morality.|||然后第二天早上，一切都变了，不是吗？安东尼·伍德维尔醒来时发现他的住宿——他的“爱彼迎”被包围了。爱德华五世同母异父的兄弟、爵士理查·格雷（伊丽莎白·伍德维尔在嫁给爱德华四世之前的小儿子）也是如此。他们被捕了。理查和白金汉去见爱德华五世。他们说里弗斯不仅是个叛徒，而且道德败坏。这是理查非常非常热衷的一个点。他非常敌视任何放荡的行为，并且极其热衷于扮演道德捍卫者的角色。
Well, clearly by the standards of the day, although he has illegitimate children, he's quite a prurient kind of person. Sure. That really comes out from his piety but i think i think but i think it's it's clear that anthony woodville was an effective guardian and this actually is precisely the problem because when richard goes and tells edward the edward v your your guardian was is a disgrace he's a traitor we've got to get rid of him but it's fine you're now i'm going to look after you um edward the fifth says i i know um yeah he was great uh i you know i think he's wonderful i love it there's a point here isn't there tom i think this is the key moment isn't there a point here though where it occurred to me if edward the fifth had been younger this wouldn't have been so much of a problem exactly so if he'd been five he would have sort of said oh okay fine okay and and off they'd have gone to london but 12 is quite old absolutely and
Well, clearly by the standards of the day, although he has illegitimate children, he's quite a prurient kind of person. Sure. That really comes out from his piety but i think i think but i think it's it's clear that anthony woodville was an effective guardian and this actually is precisely the problem because when richard goes and tells edward the edward v your your guardian was is a disgrace he's a traitor we've got to get rid of him but it's fine you're now i'm going to look after you um edward the fifth says i i know um yeah he was great uh i you know i think he's wonderful i love it there's a point here isn't there tom i think this is the key moment isn't there a point here though where it occurred to me if edward the fifth had been younger this wouldn't have been so much of a problem exactly so if he'd been five he would have sort of said oh okay fine okay and and off they'd have gone to london but 12 is quite old absolutely and|||好吧，按当时的标准来看，尽管他有私生子，但他是个相当好色的人。当然。这确实从他的虔诚中体现出来，但我认为——但我认为很明显，安东尼·伍德维尔是一个称职的监护人，这其实恰恰是问题所在。因为当理查去对爱德华五世说：“你的监护人是个耻辱，是个叛徒，我们必须除掉他，不过没关系，你现在由我来照顾”时，爱德华五世说：“我知道，嗯，他很好，呃，你知道的，我觉得他很棒，我喜欢他。”这里有一个关键点，对吧，汤姆？我认为这是关键时刻。这里有一个情况，我当时想到：如果爱德华五世更小一点，这就不会是个大问题了。完全如此，所以如果他只有五岁，他可能会说：“哦，好吧，行吧”，然后他们就去伦敦了。但12岁已经不小了，绝对是的，而且
clearly he just listens to what his uncle who he hasn't probably seen that much of not at all yeah well he's listened to his other uncle river he likes the the problem is that he sides with rivers yeah clearly and and this is this is a problem that's a definite problem and i think that everything everything follows from that because the fact that richard is confronted with the nightmare prospect that you know the lessons of history teach him which is is that once a king comes of age, it's very, very bad news for the protector. And especially if there are rival factions.
clearly he just listens to what his uncle who he hasn't probably seen that much of not at all yeah well he's listened to his other uncle river he likes the the problem is that he sides with rivers yeah clearly and and this is this is a problem that's a definite problem and i think that everything everything follows from that because the fact that richard is confronted with the nightmare prospect that you know the lessons of history teach him which is is that once a king comes of age, it's very, very bad news for the protector. And especially if there are rival factions.|||很显然，他只是听从了他的叔叔——他可能没怎么见过面，根本没见过——好吧，他听从了他喜欢的另一个叔叔里弗斯的意见。问题在于他站在了里弗斯一边，是的，很明显。这是一个问题，绝对是个问题。我认为所有事情、所有后果都由此而生，因为理查面临着一个噩梦般的前景，历史的教训告诉他：一旦国王成年，对摄政王来说就是非常非常糟糕的消息。特别是当存在敌对派系时更是如此。
Of course. Now, Tom, I'll tell you a quick fact, by the way, about this coup in Northamptonshire. So the key family around Northamptonshire at that time is a family called the Wake family. If you've read Tom Penn's book, The Brothers York, which describes... It's a wonderful book. He, is a family called the Wake family. If you've read Tom Penn's book, The Brothers York, which describes... It's a wonderful book.
Of course. Now, Tom, I'll tell you a quick fact, by the way, about this coup in Northamptonshire. So the key family around Northamptonshire at that time is a family called the Wake family. If you've read Tom Penn's book, The Brothers York, which describes... It's a wonderful book. He, is a family called the Wake family. If you've read Tom Penn's book, The Brothers York, which describes... It's a wonderful book.|||当然。顺便说一句，汤姆，我告诉你一个关于北安普顿郡这场政变的小事实。当时北安普顿郡周边的关键家族是一个叫韦克（Wake）的家族。如果你读过汤姆·潘的书《约克兄弟》（The Brothers York），书中描述了……这是一本极好的书。他提到了韦克家族。
He talks quite a lot about the Wake family. They are still in Northamptonshire and the heir to the dynasty is a listener to this podcast. Oh, goodness. Johnny Wake. How do you know that? Because his children are at school with my son.
He talks quite a lot about the Wake family. They are still in Northamptonshire and the heir to the dynasty is a listener to this podcast. Oh, goodness. Johnny Wake. How do you know that? Because his children are at school with my son.|||他花了大量篇幅讲述韦克家族。他们现在依然在北安普顿郡，而且这个家族的继承人就是本播客的听众。哦，天哪。强尼·韦克。你怎么知道的？因为他的孩子和我儿子在同一个学校上学。
That's brilliant. So this is living history i i was very excited when i discovered that and hopefully he will be too uh although they since his family took part in a coup that ended up with some infanticide whether maybe he won't appreciate me mentioning it anyway so yes so richard has taken possession of Edward. Now, Tom, we didn't mention that what Elizabeth Woodville is doing with Richard of York, because obviously when word of this... Oh, she's straight off to sanctuary again. She reads the runes. I mean, you're a big fan of hers, I know.
That's brilliant. So this is living history i i was very excited when i discovered that and hopefully he will be too uh although they since his family took part in a coup that ended up with some infanticide whether maybe he won't appreciate me mentioning it anyway so yes so richard has taken possession of Edward. Now, Tom, we didn't mention that what Elizabeth Woodville is doing with Richard of York, because obviously when word of this... Oh, she's straight off to sanctuary again. She reads the runes. I mean, you're a big fan of hers, I know.|||太精彩了。所以这是活生生的历史，我发现这一点时非常兴奋，希望他也一样。呃，不过鉴于他的家族曾参与过一场以弑婴告终的政变，也许他不会感激我提起这事。不管怎样，是的，理查已经控制了爱德华。现在，汤姆，我们还没提到伊丽莎白·伍德维尔对约克的理查（弟弟）做了什么，因为很明显，当这个消息传出时……哦，她立刻又逃进避难所了。她看穿了形势。我的意思是，我知道你是她的超级粉丝。
Her brother has been taken off to Pontefract, which, as anyone familiar with the reign of Richard II will know, terrible if you get taken to Pontefract. You're almost bound to die. Because that's where Richard II gets murdered. So, yes, Elizabeth is straight off to Westminster again. And in a way, she recognises straight away what's going on. And she can see that once Richard of Gloucester has taken taken that first step which i think he's taken for completely understandable reasons he wants to protect himself from the woodfield so once he's taken that first step of the of securing the king yeah he's trapped
Her brother has been taken off to Pontefract, which, as anyone familiar with the reign of Richard II will know, terrible if you get taken to Pontefract. You're almost bound to die. Because that's where Richard II gets murdered. So, yes, Elizabeth is straight off to Westminster again. And in a way, she recognises straight away what's going on. And she can see that once Richard of Gloucester has taken taken that first step which i think he's taken for completely understandable reasons he wants to protect himself from the woodfield so once he's taken that first step of the of securing the king yeah he's trapped|||她的兄弟被带到了庞特弗拉克特。任何熟悉理查二世统治时期的人都知道，如果被带到庞特弗拉克特，那就太可怕了。你几乎必死无疑。因为理查二世就是在那里被谋杀的。所以，是的，伊丽莎白再次径直逃往威斯敏斯特。从某种意义上说，她立刻意识到了发生了什么。她能看出，一旦格洛斯特公爵理查迈出了那第一步——我认为他出于完全可以理解的原因迈出了这一步，他想保护自己免受伍德维尔家族的侵害——一旦他迈出了确保控制国王的这第一步，是的，他就被困住了。
he's on the kind of yeah he's he's on the escalator i mean he's been on the escalator from day one though couldn't you but what then happens, because again, he comes to London, he goes to the council and he tells the council to condemn Rivers as a traitor. And the council basically turn around and say, well, where's your evidence? And it's exactly as when Richard has confronted Edward V and Edward V says, well, I like Rivers. But despite that, the council kind of go along with Richard. He's clearly the grand fromage now in the Yorkist court. Yeah, because it's about a month,
he's on the kind of yeah he's he's on the escalator i mean he's been on the escalator from day one though couldn't you but what then happens, because again, he comes to London, he goes to the council and he tells the council to condemn Rivers as a traitor. And the council basically turn around and say, well, where's your evidence? And it's exactly as when Richard has confronted Edward V and Edward V says, well, I like Rivers. But despite that, the council kind of go along with Richard. He's clearly the grand fromage now in the Yorkist court. Yeah, because it's about a month,|||他就像是……是的，他踏上了自动扶梯。我的意思是，其实他从第一天起就踏上这座电梯了，不是吗？但接下来发生了什么？因为同样地，他来到伦敦，前往议会，并告诉议会谴责里弗斯为叛徒。而议会基本上转过头来问：“嗯，你的证据在哪里？”这就像当初理查质问爱德华五世时，爱德华五世说：“嗯，我喜欢里弗斯。”但尽管如此，议会还是顺从了理查。他现在显然是约克宫廷里的头号大人物了。是的，因为大约有一个月的时间，
isn't there? Fourth of May till the 13th of June, where he's the boss. Everything seems like it might calm down. Do you not think in that period? Except that two crucial steps are taken, presumably, you know, absolutely led by Richard, one of which is to postpone um edward v's coronation to the 22nd of june that's right so that's postponed and the other notoriously is it should be lodged in the
isn't there? Fourth of May till the 13th of June, where he's the boss. Everything seems like it might calm down. Do you not think in that period? Except that two crucial steps are taken, presumably, you know, absolutely led by Richard, one of which is to postpone um edward v's coronation to the 22nd of june that's right so that's postponed and the other notoriously is it should be lodged in the|||对吧？从5月4日到6月13日，他是老大。一切看起来都可能会平静下来。难道你不觉得在那段时期内吗？除了采取了两个关键步骤外——大概吧，你知道的，绝对是由理查主导的——其中之一是将爱德华五世的加冕典礼推迟到6月22日。没错，所以加冕典礼被推迟了；另一个臭名昭著的举动是，他应该被安置在伦敦塔内。
tower but that's not inherently sinister that's not that ominous because at that point there's no record of killing people in the tower particularly i mean some people have died henry the sixth okay it's but the tower it is a prison as well as a royal residence it is but i think when people hear that about the tower they think about henry the eighth and his wives they think oh it means the chopping block it doesn't it's right it's the main royal complex in london i think the scary thing for edward the fifth and for people his sort of pals is that he is surrounded by richard's men richard has total control of him at this stage. So he's cut off from the Woodvilles.
tower but that's not inherently sinister that's not that ominous because at that point there's no record of killing people in the tower particularly i mean some people have died henry the sixth okay it's but the tower it is a prison as well as a royal residence it is but i think when people hear that about the tower they think about henry the eighth and his wives they think oh it means the chopping block it doesn't it's right it's the main royal complex in london i think the scary thing for edward the fifth and for people his sort of pals is that he is surrounded by richard's men richard has total control of him at this stage. So he's cut off from the Woodvilles.|||但那本身并非极其邪恶，也没有那么不祥，因为当时没有特别的记录表明在伦敦塔里杀过人——我是说有些人死过，比如亨利六世，好吧。但伦敦塔既是监狱也是皇家住所。确实是这样，但我觉得当人们听到关于伦敦塔的这些时，他们会想到亨利八世和他的妻子们，他们会想：“哦，这意味着断头台。”其实并非如此。没错，它是伦敦主要的皇家建筑群。我认为对爱德华五世以及他那些同伴来说，可怕的事情在于他被理查的人包围了，理查在这个阶段完全控制了他。所以他被切断了与伍德维尔家族的联系。
His uncles are, you know, his uncle is in captivity and he is utterly at the mercy of Richard's guards. That's the sort of scary thing. But at that point, does he think he's in danger of his life? Surely not. Well, Richard wants, so on the 10th of June, he summons basically a massive army from the north. So the entire agreement
His uncles are, you know, his uncle is in captivity and he is utterly at the mercy of Richard's guards. That's the sort of scary thing. But at that point, does he think he's in danger of his life? Surely not. Well, Richard wants, so on the 10th of June, he summons basically a massive army from the north. So the entire agreement|||他的叔叔们……你知道的，他的一个叔叔被关押，而他完全任由理查的卫兵摆布。这才是可怕的地方。但在那个时候，他觉得自己有生命危险吗？肯定不会。好吧，理查想要……所以在6月10日，他基本上从北方召集了一支庞大的军队。所以之前关于
that people wouldn't bring in large armies, Richard parks that. And we talked about Blackadder. Yeah. It's taken by Sir Richard Ratcliffe, who is played in the Ian McKellen film of Richard III by Tim McEnany, who's Darling. Oh, right.
that people wouldn't bring in large armies, Richard parks that. And we talked about Blackadder. Yeah. It's taken by Sir Richard Ratcliffe, who is played in the Ian McKellen film of Richard III by Tim McEnany, who's Darling. Oh, right.|||人们不带大军进城的协议，理查直接把它搁置了。我们之前讨论过《黑爵士》。是的。这个角色由理查·拉特克利夫爵士扮演，在伊恩·麦克莱恩主演的电影《理查三世》中，他由蒂姆·麦克纳尼扮演，也就是达林（Darling）。哦，对。
Percy. Yeah, Percy. Yeah. Yeah. So a little connection there. Three days later, isn't it, that you start to get, you have this incredible scene which Shakespeare famously, brilliantly recreates.
Percy. Yeah, Percy. Yeah. Yeah. So a little connection there. Three days later, isn't it, that you start to get, you have this incredible scene which Shakespeare famously, brilliantly recreates.|||珀西。对，珀西。是的。所以这里有个小小的关联。三天后，对吧，你开始看到，你拥有了这个令人难以置信的场景，莎士比亚对其进行了著名且精彩的重现。
Because the other key figure has been Hastings who was basically the ultimate Edward IV loyalist and is loyal to the house I think clearly stands for compromise so I think reading between the lines what's happened is that in the days just
Because the other key figure has been Hastings who was basically the ultimate Edward IV loyalist and is loyal to the house I think clearly stands for compromise so I think reading between the lines what's happened is that in the days just|||因为另一个关键人物是黑斯廷斯，他基本上是爱德华四世的终极忠臣，对家族忠心耿耿。我认为他显然主张妥协。所以我觉得，字里行间可以看出发生的事情是：在接下来的几天里——
reading up to this council meeting on the 13th of June Richard has probably sounded out Hastings and said you know where do we go from here i could be king you know i don't have to be but i could be and maybe that would sort of allow you know we could we could kind of knock out the woodvilles completely just take them out the equation if i'm king and you can be number two or something. And Hastings probably said, no, I think Edward V has to be king. Because he's loyal to Edward. He's loyal to Edward IV and therefore to the line. And ultimately, his loyalty to Edward IV is greater than his hostility to Elizabeth Woodville.
reading up to this council meeting on the 13th of June Richard has probably sounded out Hastings and said you know where do we go from here i could be king you know i don't have to be but i could be and maybe that would sort of allow you know we could we could kind of knock out the woodvilles completely just take them out the equation if i'm king and you can be number two or something. And Hastings probably said, no, I think Edward V has to be king. Because he's loyal to Edward. He's loyal to Edward IV and therefore to the line. And ultimately, his loyalty to Edward IV is greater than his hostility to Elizabeth Woodville.|||临近6月13日的这次议会会议前夕，理查很可能试探过黑斯廷斯，说：“你知道，我们接下来去向何方？我可以成为国王——你知道，我不一定非得当，但我也许可以。也许这样一来……你知道，我们可以彻底击溃伍德维尔家族，把他们排除在权力方程之外。如果我当国王，你可以当老二或者别的什么。”而黑斯廷斯大概说：“不，我认为爱德华五世必须当国王。”因为他对爱德华忠诚。他效忠于爱德华四世，因此也效忠于王统。归根结底，他对爱德华四世的忠诚，大于他对伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的敌意。
And so therefore, he is an Edward V loyalist. And I think at that point, Richard thinks it's that classic thing that we saw with Vitellius. Yeah. Richard thinks, oh God, well, if he's not going to be on my side, what am I going to do? I've got to kill him. I've got to kill him now.
And so therefore, he is an Edward V loyalist. And I think at that point, Richard thinks it's that classic thing that we saw with Vitellius. Yeah. Richard thinks, oh God, well, if he's not going to be on my side, what am I going to do? I've got to kill him. I've got to kill him now.|||因此，他是爱德华五世的忠实拥护者。我认为就在那一刻，理查想到了我们在维特利乌斯身上看到的经典一幕。是的。理查心想：“天哪，好吧，如果他不站在我这边，我该怎么办？我必须杀了他。我现在就得杀了他。”
And I think that's absolutely what happens. It's interesting. So in Shakespeare's play, Richard says, look, you know, I've been bewitched and shows his withered arm. Yeah. But actually, what he's doing is he's accusing Elizabeth Woodville of using witchcraft against him.
And I think that's absolutely what happens. It's interesting. So in Shakespeare's play, Richard says, look, you know, I've been bewitched and shows his withered arm. Yeah. But actually, what he's doing is he's accusing Elizabeth Woodville of using witchcraft against him.|||我认为事情绝对就是这样发生的。很有趣的是，在莎士比亚的戏剧中，理查说：“看，你知道的，我被施了魔法，”并露出了他枯萎的手臂。是的。但实际上，他这么做是在指控伊丽莎白·伍德维尔对其实施了巫术。
And that's obviously calculated to get Hastings on board because Hastings hates the Woodvilles. But Hastings hesitates and says no, and so Richard has him executed. Yes, he does. And one of Hastings' man, it's interesting, this sort of Game of Thrones type dimension, because Hastings' great deputy was a man called Sir William Catesby.
And that's obviously calculated to get Hastings on board because Hastings hates the Woodvilles. But Hastings hesitates and says no, and so Richard has him executed. Yes, he does. And one of Hastings' man, it's interesting, this sort of Game of Thrones type dimension, because Hastings' great deputy was a man called Sir William Catesby.|||这显然是经过精心算计的，目的是把黑斯廷斯拉拢过来，因为黑斯廷斯恨伍德维尔家族。但黑斯廷斯犹豫了，说“不”，于是理查下令将他处决。是的，他确实这么做了。有趣的是，黑斯廷斯的手下之一带有这种《权力的游戏》式的维度，因为黑斯廷斯得力的副手是一个名叫威廉·凯茨比爵士的人。
And he ditches Hastings at this point. Clearly, Richard has suborned him in some way. He turns on Hastings. And Hastings is effectively, he's basically dragged out of the council, isn't he? Taken off to the chopping block. Yeah, yeah.
And he ditches Hastings at this point. Clearly, Richard has suborned him in some way. He turns on Hastings. And Hastings is effectively, he's basically dragged out of the council, isn't he? Taken off to the chopping block. Yeah, yeah.|||他在这时抛弃了黑斯廷斯。显然，理查通过某种方式收买了他。他背叛了黑斯廷斯。黑斯廷斯实际上……他基本上是被拖出了议会大厅，不是吗？被拉去砍头了。对，对。
And then three days later, again, kind of in the Olivier film, brilliant scene when the young Richard of Shrewsbury is released by Elizabeth Woodville. So he's the nine-year-old brother. Yeah. And there's a kind of a terrifying exchange between them where he the little boy jokes with Richard and Richard kind of fixes him with his stare. Very, very sinister moment, whether it seems sinister to people.
And then three days later, again, kind of in the Olivier film, brilliant scene when the young Richard of Shrewsbury is released by Elizabeth Woodville. So he's the nine-year-old brother. Yeah. And there's a kind of a terrifying exchange between them where he the little boy jokes with Richard and Richard kind of fixes him with his stare. Very, very sinister moment, whether it seems sinister to people.|||然后三天后，同样地，在奥利弗的电影中有一个精彩的场景：年轻的什鲁斯伯里的理查被伊丽莎白·伍德维尔释放了。他是那个九岁的弟弟。是的。他们之间有一段可怕的对话，小男孩跟理查开玩笑，而理查用死死的目光盯着他。这是一个非常非常阴森的时刻，不管人们是否觉得它阴森。
But I mean, it must people must be starting to. Well, presumably at this point. Soabeth woodville hands her son over out of sanctuary to join his older brother in the tower and presumably she does this because she thinks okay coronation is going ahead at this point well she thinks richard is clearly determined he's going to be a protector he's going to be the big man the thing to do now is appease him yeah you know give him my younger son the coronation is still on the coronation is still supposedly going to happen on the 22nd of june but once as soon as richard senior has got hold of the little boy he says actually no the coronation is not going to happen until november
But I mean, must people must be starting to. Well, presumably at this point. Soabeth woodville hands her son over out of sanctuary to join his older brother in the tower and presumably she does this because she thinks okay coronation is going ahead at this point well she thinks richard is clearly determined he's going to be a protector he's going to be the big man the thing to do now is appease him yeah you know give him my younger son the coronation is still on the coronation is still supposedly going to happen on the 22nd of june but once as soon as richard senior has got hold of the little boy he says actually no the coronation is not going to happen until november|||但我的意思是，人们肯定开始……好吧，大概就在这个时候。所以，伊丽莎白·伍德维尔把她的儿子交出避难所，去伦敦塔和他的哥哥团聚。我想她这么做是因为她觉得：好吧，加冕典礼现在要进行了。嗯，她认为理查显然决心要当摄政王，他要成为这里的大人物，现在该做的是安抚他。是的，你知道的，把我的小儿子交给他，加冕典礼还在继续，加冕典礼据说仍然会在6月22日举行。但一旦——老理查一拿到那个小男孩，他就说：“事实上，不，加冕典礼要到11月才举行了。”
now yeah and at that point you're like is it ever going to happen yes um and then and then there's a sermon preached on the 22nd of june isn't there yeah ralph shaw and he he says i mean they have two arguments don't they not even just one which is clearly a sign that you know your arguments are a bad one yeah so first of all this guy says edward the fourth was completely illegitimate anyway he was a bastard so richard basically accuses his own mother of sleeping around yeah yeah um cecily cecily neville he says you know she she wasn't faithful to my father anyway i mean edward the fourth wasn't even my brother and look at clarence as well because he says he says um edward and edward and clarence didn't look anything like their father
now yeah and at that point you're like is it ever going to happen yes um and then and then there's a sermon preached on the 22nd of june isn't there yeah ralph shaw and he he says i mean they have two arguments don't they not even just one which is clearly a sign that you know your arguments are a bad one yeah so first of all this guy says edward the fourth was completely illegitimate anyway he was a bastard so richard basically accuses his own mother of sleeping around yeah yeah— cecily cecily neville he says you know she she wasn't faithful to my father anyway i mean edward the fourth wasn't even my brother and look at clarence as well because he says he says um edward and edward and clarence didn't look anything like their father|||现在，是的。而在那个时候你会想：这加冕典礼到底还会不会举行？是的。然后，然后在6月22日发表了一场布道，不是吗？是的，拉尔夫·肖，他说——我的意思是，他们有两个论点，甚至不止一个，这显然表明你知道你的论据站不住脚。是的。所以首先，这家伙说爱德华四世无论如何完全是个私生子，他是个杂种。所以理查基本上指控他自己的母亲到处跟人鬼混。是的，是的——塞西莉·内维尔，他说：“你知道，她对我的父亲并不忠诚。我的意思是，爱德华四世甚至不是我的兄弟，再看看克拉伦斯也是如此，”因为他说，“爱德华、爱德华和克拉伦斯长得一点都不像他们的父亲。”
yeah but i do but then he then the other argument is um he wasn't any and he wasn't married to elizabeth woodville anyway because he had there'd been a pre-contract with another woman eleanor talbot later conveniently dead yeah so so not only is he a bastard was he a bastard my brother but my nephews are bastards too um now think even the most devoted Ricardian has some, you know, it's a guy who's prepared to kind of say that about his mother simply so that he can displace his nephew. But he's desperate though at this point, don't you think? Yes, but it's poor form, Dominic.
yeah but i do but then he then the other argument is um he wasn't any and he wasn't married to elizabeth woodville anyway because he had there'd been a pre-contract with another woman eleanor talbot later conveniently dead yeah so so not only is he a bastard was he a bastard my brother but my nephews are bastards too um now think even the most devoted Ricardian has some, you know, it's a guy who's prepared to kind of say that about his mother simply so that he can displace his nephew. But he's desperate though at this point, don't you think? Yes, but it's poor form, Dominic.|||是的，但我——但随后他提出的另一个论点是：他根本没有——而且他无论如何也没有娶伊丽莎白·伍德维尔，因为他之前跟另一个女人埃莉诺·塔尔伯特有过婚约（后来很巧地死了）。所以，不仅我兄弟是个私生子，我的侄子们也是私生子。现在想想，即使是最忠实的理查三世拥护者也有点……你知道的，这是一个为了取代侄子而准备这样说自己母亲的家伙。但他此时也是走投无路了，你不觉得吗？是的，但这吃相太难看了，多米尼克。
I suppose it is poor form. Don't you think? I mean, I don't think that's... That's not filial behaviour. No, no, it's not filial. I mean, it's definitely not very filial behaviour. And I think pretty much straight afterwards, the Duke of Buckingham, who's this sort of Weasley figure we mentioned earlier,
I suppose it is poor form. Don't you think? I mean, I don't think that's... That's not filial behaviour. No, no, it's not filial. I mean, it's definitely not very filial behaviour. And I think pretty much straight afterwards, the Duke of Buckingham, who's this sort of Weasley figure we mentioned earlier,|||我想这确实吃相难看。你不觉得吗？我的意思是，我不认为那是……那不是孝顺的行为。不，不，不孝顺。我的意思是，这绝对不是什么孝顺的行为。而且我认为几乎紧接着，白金汉公爵——就是我们刚才提到过的那种像韦斯利（Weasley）一样滑头的人物——
who's basically attached himself to Richard as chief ally, he goes to the guild hall, doesn't he? And orchestrates these calls. He says, oh, we should give Richard the... Again, brilliant in the play. The guards all sort of all right yeah what a great idea basically being you know given a groat each or something to to shout this and then it's all very swift incredibly swift so the 25th of june um the princes are declared illegitimate and the thing you know the further thing that i think marks this out is deeply treacherous is that all these rumours about the illegitimacy of the princes and the illegitimacy of Edward's marriage to Elizabeth Woodville.
who's basically attached himself to Richard as chief ally, he goes to the guild hall, doesn't he? And orchestrates these calls. He says, oh, we should give Richard the... Again, brilliant in the play. The guards all sort of all right yeah what a great idea basically being you know given a groat each or something to to shout this and then it's all very swift incredibly swift so the 25th of june um the princes are declared illegitimate and the thing you know the further thing that i think marks this out is deeply treacherous is that all these rumours about the illegitimacy of the princes and the illegitimacy of Edward's marriage to Elizabeth Woodville.|||他基本上作为首席盟友依附于理查，他去了市政厅，对吧？并策划了这些呼声。他说：“哦，我们应该把王位交给理查……”同样，在戏剧中这非常精彩：卫兵们都表现得“好吧，好主意”，基本上每人被给了一格罗特（groat）左右的报酬来大声喊叫。然后这一切都非常迅速，快得不可思议。所以6月25日，嗯，王子们被宣布为私生子。而我认为标志着这一行为极其叛逆的另一件事是，所有这些关于王子们非婚生以及爱德华与伊丽莎白·伍德维尔的婚姻非法的谣言——
It all originated in the swirl of kind of calumnies and propaganda that had accompanied the coup against Edward back in 1470. Yeah, the Warwick coup. Exactly. They're resuscitating old rulers. So they're resuscitating all that. But is it, Tom, I'm very hesitant to, more hesitant than you are to say, oh, this is terrible villainy.
It all originated in the swirl of kind of calumnies and propaganda that had accompanied the coup against Edward back in 1470. Yeah, the Warwick coup. Exactly. They're resuscitating old rulers. So they're resuscitating all that. But is it, Tom, I'm very hesitant to, more hesitant than you are to say, oh, this is terrible villainy.|||这一切都起源于1470年针对爱德华的政变时伴随的种种诽谤和宣传风暴。是的，沃里克政变。没错。他们在复活旧的谣言。所以他们在把这一切死灰复燃。但是，汤姆，我非常犹豫——比你更犹豫——去说：“哦，这是可怕的罪恶。”
This is, I think, all it would have taken would be for Richard to have won one battle and we would be telling this story differently, I think. We would be telling it as ruthless i don't think so and and very hard-nosed but i think we would say frankly this is medieval politics this is what henry the fourth did to it it's not second it's not though it's not it's because it's got kids but that's bad luck that is richard's bad luck it's nephews and you think about the other king who murdered his nephew.
This is, I think, all it would have taken would be for Richard to have won one battle and we would be telling this story differently, I think. We would be telling it as ruthless i don't think so and and very hard-nosed but i think we would say frankly this is medieval politics this is what henry the fourth did to it it's not second it's not though it's not it's because it's got kids but that's bad luck that is richard's bad luck it's nephews and you think about the other king who murdered his nephew.|||我认为，这一切只需要理查赢得一场战役，我们就会以不同的方式讲述这个故事了。我们会把它讲成是冷酷无情——我不这么认为——而且非常强硬的政治手腕，但我想我们会坦诚地说：这就是中世纪政治，这就是亨利四世对它做的事。这不一样，这不是——不对，这不是，因为这涉及小孩子。但这真是不走运，那是理查的霉运，那是他的亲侄子。你想想另一个谋杀自己侄子的国王。
And I've given away there, the fact that I think that Richard is responsible for the murder of the prince in the tower is John. And the two Kings who have had the worst reputations in English history are John and Richard the third. And I think it's no coincidence that they were both at least believed to be guilty of the same crime. And you can argue whether they really were, but that was their reputation.
And I've given away there, the fact that I think that Richard is responsible for the murder of the prince in the tower is John. And the two Kings who have had the worst reputations in English history are John and Richard the third. And I think it's no coincidence that they were both at least believed to be guilty of the same crime. And you can argue whether they really were, but that was their reputation.|||我已经泄露了我的观点，我认为理查对塔中王子的谋杀负有责任，而另一个是约翰王。英国历史上名声最差的两个国王就是约翰王和理查三世。我认为这绝非巧合，他们至少都被认为犯下了同样的罪行。你可以争论他们是否真的犯了罪，但他们的名声就是这样。
They're totally different characters, though, Tom. Of course. I mean, John is famously weak. But Dominic, the thing is that this is not normal behaviour at all. Yeah, but it's not a normal position. Of course it's not. Richard is in. I agree.
They're totally different characters, though, Tom. Of course. I mean, John is famously weak. But Dominic, the thing is that this is not normal behaviour at all. Yeah, but it's not a normal position. Of course it's not. Richard is in. I agree.|||但他们是完全不同的人物，汤姆。当然。我的意思是，约翰王以懦弱闻名。但多米尼克，问题在于这根本不是正常行为。是的，但这也不是一个正常的处境。当然不是。理查身处其中。我同意。
And incredibly. Yeah, he's firefighting. yeah but it's not a normal position of course it's richard is in i i agree and incredibly yeah he's he's he's firefighting he basically he doesn't do any of the steps that he does he probably thinks he will die i entirely accept that but i i still think that um you know accusing your your mother of sleeping around um It's like the plot of EastEnders. It is very. While all the while, you know, plotting to get rid of your nephews, resuscitating rumours spread about
And incredibly. Yeah, he's firefighting. yeah but it's not a normal position of course it's richard is in i i agree and incredibly yeah he's he's he's firefighting he basically he doesn't do any of the steps that he does he probably thinks he will die i entirely accept that but i i still think that um you know accusing your your mother of sleeping around—|||而且极度……是的，他在疲于应付危机。是的，但这并不是一个正常的处境，当然不是。理查所处的处境——我同意，而且极其……是的，他在四处救火。他基本上……如果他不采取他所做的那些步骤，他很可能会死，我完全接受这一点。但我仍然认为，呃，你知道的，指控你的母亲到处跟人鬼混——
by your own family's enemies. You've lost Philippa Langley as a listener. I'll tell you that now. Yeah, probably. Probably. But I think it's... and then when you throw into that the kind of, the tone of sanctimony, which I thought, you know, is the expression
It's like the plot of EastEnders. It is very. While all the while, you know, (plotting to get rid of your nephews), resuscitating rumours spread about by your own family's enemies. You've lost Philippa Langley as a listener. I'll tell you that now. Yeah, probably. Probably. But I think it's... and then when you throw into that the kind of, the tone of sanctimony, which I thought, you know, is the expression of an authentic Christian sensibility, but it does slightly, it makes him seem an unpleasant figure, I think. I think we've been, since we've been talking for almost half an hour and you're getting more and more judgmental. Well, hold on. Hold on. Let's have him crowned. So let's get him crowned. So so the princes are declared illegitimate.|||这就像是肥皂剧《东区人》的剧情。确实很像。而与此同时，你知道的（策划除掉你的侄子们），死灰复燃那些由你家族的敌人散布的谣言。你已经失去菲利帕·兰利这个听众了。我现在就告诉你。是的，很可能。很可能。但我认为这是……当你再加上那种假装神圣的语气时——我认为你知道的，这是一种真实基督教情怀的表达，但它确实有点……这让他看起来像个讨厌的人物，我这么认为。我觉得我们已经谈了快半小时了，而你变得越来越爱评头论足了。好吧，等等。等等。让我们让他加冕吧。所以让我们给他加冕。所以——王子们被宣布为私生子。
of an authentic Christian sensibility, but it does slightly, it makes him seem an unpleasant figure, I think. I think we've been, since we've been talking for almost half an hour and you're getting more and more judgmental. Well, hold on. Hold on. Let's have him crowned. So let's get him crowned. So so the princes are declared illegitimate.
Yeah. Rivers and Richard Gray are executed. Yeah. Pontefract Rivers has written a rather stylish poem. And, you know, he's very cool even on the shopping block and on the 6th of July Richard is crowned and lots of people turn up but lots of people don't Elizabeth Woodville is not there and who else is not there|||是的。里弗斯和理查·格雷被处决了。是的。在庞特弗拉克特，里弗斯写了一首相当有文采的诗。而且，你知道的，即使在断头台上他也非常冷静。7月6日，理查加冕了，很多人出席了，但也有很多人没来。伊丽莎白·伍德维尔不在，还有谁不在？
Yeah. Rivers and Richard Gray are executed. Yeah. Pontefract Rivers has written a rather stylish poem. And, you know, he's very cool even on the shopping block and on the 6th of July Richard is crowned and lots of people turn up but lots of people don't Elizabeth Woodville is not there and who else is not there
Well Edward V is not there really interestingly there had been plans for him to attain the coronation they had ordered him clothes and shoes and spurs and horses so weirdly although he'd been declared illegitimate he was going to attend his uncle's coronation which i suppose would have been the ultimate kind of affirmation of the new regime that even the kids themselves yeah except accept it but. Except it. But he's not there. And at this point, there are,|||嗯，爱德华五世不在。真是有趣，原本有计划让他参加加冕典礼，他们甚至为他订购了衣服、鞋子、马刺和马。所以奇怪的是，尽管他被宣布为私生子，他还是要出席他叔叔的加冕典礼——我想这将会是对新政权的终极肯定，连孩子们自己也……是的，接受它，但是。接受它。但他不在那里。而在此时，有——
Well Edward V is not there really interestingly there had been plans for him to attain the coronation they had ordered him clothes and shoes and spurs and horses so weirdly although he'd been declared illegitimate he was going to attend his uncle's coronation which i suppose would have been the ultimate kind of affirmation of the new regime that even the kids themselves yeah except accept it but. Except it. But he's not there. And at this point, there are,
爱德华五世实际上并不在那里，有趣的是，本来曾有计划让他参加加冕典礼，他们曾为他订购了衣服、鞋子、马刺和马匹，所以很奇怪，尽管他被宣布为私生子，但他本要出席他叔叔的加冕典礼，我想这可以说是对新政权终极的肯定，甚至孩子们自己也……是的，除了接受它。除了接受他。但他不在那儿。而在此时，有，
there's a trace reference which we'll come to perhaps after the break of him in captivity. But at this point, the princes themselves effectively leave the story. So this is the point I think
也许我们在中场休息后会讲到，有一个关于他被囚禁的线索追踪。但此时，王子们实际上已经退出了故事。所以我觉得这就是我们
at which we should take a break and we can return after the break and we will be solving the mystery of the princess and their tower i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
应该休息一下的时候了，休息过后我们还会回来，我们将揭开王子和塔的谜团。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的都是娱乐》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告节目、独家番外集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are poised to solve the mystery of the princes and the tower. So Richard III has been crowned on the 6th of July. His two nephews did not turn up at the coronation.
以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的沉淀》。我们将要解开王子与塔的谜团。因此，理查德三世已于 7 月 6 日加冕。他的两个侄子没有出席加冕典礼。
We know that that summer they are seen playing in the gardens at the Tower of London complex. A prison is part of it, but it's not just a prison. It's a kind of royal complex. They are seen practicing archery. There is talk of it, but it's not just a prison. It's a kind of royal complex. They are seen practicing archery. There is talk of faces at windows. But at some point that summer, their household servants are dismissed. And then they are never seen again.
我们知道那年夏天有人看到他们在伦敦塔建筑群的花园里玩耍。监狱是其中的一部分，但它不仅是一座监狱。它是一种皇家建筑群。有人看到他们在练习射击。有人谈论过窗户边的面孔。但在那个夏天的某个时候，他们的家政仆人被解雇了。然后就再也没有人见过他们。
So, Tom, I mean, this is the key question. What happens to them? So we've got the question from Megan Young. Do you think the princes were murdered and if so when and by whom um i would have thought the overwhelming probabilities that they were murdered and that it was done on richard's orders and absolute certainty on this obviously is impossible because otherwise people wouldn't be debating it to this day. So we're not going to solve it because no definitive solution is ultimately possible.
所以，汤姆，我的意思是，这是最关键的问题。他们怎么了？我们收到了梅根·杨的问题。你认为王子们是被谋杀的吗？如果是的话，是什么时候、被谁谋杀的？嗯，我本以为压倒性的可能是他们被谋杀的，而且这是奉理查德的命令做的。对此绝对肯定显然是不可能的，否则人们就不会争论到今天了。所以我们不会解决这个问题，因为最终不可能有明确的解决方案。
But I would I think the overwhelming probability is that they were murdered and Richard did it. So let's look at the other candidate. Go on then. Yeah. The other major. There's really only one candidate i would say other than richard didn't he wouldn't you which would be buckingham yeah agreed so buckingham is constable of england he has been rewarded so he might conceivably have access to the tower though it's very hard
但我认为，极大的可能是他们被谋杀的，而且是理查德干的。那我们来看看另一个候选人。那就说吧。对。另一个主要的。说实话，除了理查德之外，我只能说还有一个候选人，难道不是吗？那就是白金汉。是的，同意。所以白金汉是英格兰的治安官，他受到了奖赏，所以他很可能会接触到那座塔，虽然这非常困难。
that's the very hard to see how he has access without richard's knowledge because Richard is the king he his men control everything so to me it's hard to see how Buckingham and also the the so Buckingham is the we open this episode with the quotation from the daughter of time by Josephine Tay in the Josephine Tay's book her detective Alan Grant is laid up in hospital with a broken leg and he's and he and he falls to solving the mystery of the princes in their town. He reads all the evidence and he decides that Buckingham did it. And Richard's enthusiasts have often thought that Buckingham did it. So there's a really brilliant book, which I loved when I was about 12, a great biography of Richard III, probably the definitive
非常难看出他是如何在理查德不知情的情况下接触到的，因为理查德是国王，他的手下控制着一切。所以在我看来，很难看出白金汉以及……白金汉就是——我们在本集开头引用了约瑟芬·泰的《时间的女儿》中的名言。在约瑟芬·泰的书中，她的侦探艾伦·格兰特因断腿卧床休养，然后他开始着手解开王子和塔的谜团。他阅读了所有的证据，并断定是白金汉干的。理查德的拥护者经常认为这是白金汉干的。所以有一本非常棒的书，我大约12岁时非常喜欢它，它是理查德三世的一部伟大传记，对许多理查德主义者来说可能是决定性的
one for a lot of Ricardians by an American academic called Paul Murray Kendall. And he has this big appendix in which he also thinks that Buckingham did it. And he sort of says Buckingham was playing a long game. He had his eye on the throne. He probably acted without Richard knowing. He had access to the tower. I ultimately find that a bit implausible. I think Richard is so clearly the man in charge.
一本由美国学者保罗·默里·肯德尔撰写的书。他有一个很大的附录，其中他也认为白金汉干的。他有点像说白金汉在下一盘大棋。他一直盯着王位。他可能是在理查德不知情的情况下行事的。他可以接触到塔。我最终觉得这有点不可信。我认为理查德显然是负责任的人。
And he's the obvious person with most gain. And again, I mean, it would be like if Buckingham were responsible, it would be in the way that Richard would have been responsible for the murder of Henry VI, i.e. not ultimately, because it was Edward IV. The buck stops with the king. Yeah. And, you know. The counter-argument is, Tom, that Richard is weakened
而且他是最有可能获益的人。再说一次，我的意思是，如果白金汉负有责任，那就像理查德对亨利六世的谋杀负有责任一样，也就是说最终不是他，因为那是爱德华四世。责任最终落在国王身上。对。而且，你知道。反驳的观点是，汤姆，理查德被削弱了
by the deaths of the two boys because people hold it against him. And he doesn't immediately gain anything by it. But I would say, in answer to that, there is the first revolt, isn't there, in late July. So within a month of his coronation, there is an attempt by some conspirators to rescue the two boys and to stage a sort of pro-woodville countercoup yeah and i mean all everything you know about thousands of years of history is that when that kind of thing happens the person in charge decides usually will get rid of the focus of of of resistance you know get rid of the alternative candidates. That's what dictators, kings, emperors have done throughout all history.
由于两个男孩的死去，人们因此记恨他。而且他并没有从中立即获得什么好处。但我想说的是，作为对这一点的回应，在7月底确实发生了第一次起义，不是吗？所以在他的加冕礼后一个月内，一些阴谋家试图营救这两个男孩，并策划了一场亲伍德维尔的反政变。是的，我的意思是，你对几千年来历史的了解就是，当那种事情发生时，负责的人通常会决定铲除抵抗势力的核心力量（你知道的），铲除潜在的替代人选。这就是独裁者、国王、皇帝在整个历史中所做的事情。
So it would make complete sense for Richard at that point to say, oh, my God, they've got to go. I can't keep having these revolts. And I don't think that's because he's evil and malignant. I just think that's because he's hard-headed. It's a calculus of power. Yeah. And I think the other thing that militates against the idea that Buckingham did it is that Richard actually had the...
所以理查德在那时说“天哪，他们必须走。我不能再忍受这些起义了”是完全合情合理的。我不认为这是因为他邪恶和恶毒。我只是觉得这是因为他很强硬。这是权力的算计。是的。我认为另一个反对白金汉干的观点的理由是，理查德实际上拥有……
I mean, the problem for Richard is that people are starting to say they've been murdered. So the obvious way to counter that is to produce them. So if you can't produce them, that is very, very suspicious, I think. If they're dead, you can't produce them, then obviously the idea would be to try and blame someone for it. And the ideal opportunity takes place when Buckingham, who has not been rewarded as he feels fit, joins in a rebellion that aims to bring Henry Tudor, the only conceivable Lancastrian claimant, to the throne. And this revolt is defeated. Buckingham is captured. He is taken to Salisbury. He is taken to a courtyard between the Blue
我的意思是，理查德的问题在于人们开始说他们被谋杀了。所以解决这个问题的显而易见的方法就是把他们带出来。所以如果你拿不出他们来，那就非常非常可疑了，我认为。如果他们死了，你拿不出他们来，那么显然后果就是试图把这事嫁祸给别人。而最理想的机会发生在白金汉加入了一场叛乱之时，因为他没有得到他认为合适的奖赏，这场叛乱旨在将亨利·都铎（唯一可能的兰开斯特王位继承人）推上王位。这场起义被平息了。白金汉被捕。他被带到了索尔兹伯里。他被带到布鲁尔
Boar Inn and the Saracens' Head Inn. Off with his head, so much for Buckingham in the famous cry of Richard III in Shakespeare's play. And Buckingham's head is severed in, I think I've already mentioned this, what becomes the laundry department of Debenhams in Salisbury, which has sadly since closed. A lovely detail. But for a long time, you know, you go in to buy a bra and, whoa, Dick Buckingham would pop up carrying his head well you know what richard said about buckingham's rebels he said they were horrible adulterers and boards so in
野猪客栈和萨拉森之头客栈之间的一个庭院。砍掉他的头，正如莎士比亚戏剧中理查德三世著名的呐喊“白金汉到此为止”一样。白金汉的头颅在索尔兹伯里的德本汉姆百货公司的洗衣部被砍掉了（我想我已经提到过这一点了），遗憾的是该店后来倒闭了。一个可爱的细节。但在很长一段时间里，你知道的，你进去买胸罩，然后，哇，迪克·白金汉会突然出现，手里拿着他的脑袋。好吧，你知道理查德对白金汉的叛军说了什么吗？他说他们是可怕的通奸者和叛徒，所以
a way they're kind of ladies underwear departments of a mid-market department store makes complete yeah so buckingham's buckingham's died a traitor so it's the perfect opportunity for richard to say oh well buckingham did it yeah but he doesn't no he doesn't I mean the other candidate that sometimes people so I've been to the Richard the third experience or whatever it's called in Leicester and you can vote there's a sort of interactive element where you can vote about who you think did it Richard Buckingham or Henry Tudor and some people say Henry Tudor killed them. Very, very ardent Ricardians sometimes say this.
在某种程度上，他们有点像中端百货公司的女士内衣部，这完全说得通。是的，所以白金汉作为一个叛徒死去了。所以对于理查德来说，这是一个绝佳的机会，可以顺水推舟地说：“哦，好吧，是白金汉干的。”是的，但他没有，他没有。我的意思是，有时人们提到的另一个候选人——我去过莱斯特的“理查德三世体验馆”或诸如此类的地方，你可以在那里投票，有一个互动环节，你可以投票选出你认为是谁干的：理查德、白金汉还是亨利·都铎。有些人说是亨利·都铎杀了他们。非常非常狂热的理查德主义者有时会这么说。
But again, I think that's very, very implausible. Because I think... Well, Margaret Beaufort, his mother, is another candidate, isn't it? What have they been doing in the... What have the kids been doing in the interim? Well, I'll tell you the other thing about Margaret Beaufort, who's Henry Tudor's mother, is that she reaches an accommodation with Elizabeth Woodville, who's still in sanctuary. And the only conceivable reason for that
但同样，我认为这非常非常不可信。因为我认为……好吧，他的母亲玛格丽特·博福特是另一个候选人，不是吗？这段时间孩子们都在干什么？好吧，关于亨利·都铎的母亲玛格丽特·博福特，我要告诉你的另一件事是，她与仍在避难所的伊丽莎白·伍德维尔达成了一种妥协。唯一可能的理由
is that they would both, you know, that they would have for that is that Elizabeth Woodville assumes that her children are dead. Although, Tom, there is an interesting problem with the Richard III, the explanation that places Richard III
他们这样做是因为伊丽莎白·伍德维尔认为她的孩子们已经死了。尽管，汤姆，关于理查德三世，把理查德三世描述为
as the murderer. And that is that Elizabeth Woodville also reaches an accommodation with Richard herself. So March 1484, she leaves sanctuary and then reappears at court, which is a kind of slightly weird thing to do. If she thinks her sons have...
凶手的解释有一个有趣的问题。那就是伊丽莎白·伍德维尔也与理查德本人达成了妥协。所以在1484年3月，她离开了避难所，然后重新出现在宫廷里，这有点奇怪。如果她认为她的儿子们……
Well, I suppose your argument would be she feels she has no choice. Well, she's also thinking about her daughter. She doesn't want to be... you know she's assuming i guess that it's likely that richard will will carry on i mean she's trying to play both you know she's reaching accommodation with margaret beaufort to try and reach out to henry the seventh as he will become that he will marry her daughter elizabeth which in due course is of course exactly what happens um but he's she's also kind of talking, you know, what's my fate going to be? What's the fate of my other children going to be under Richard?
好吧，我想你的论点会是她觉得她别无选择。好吧，她也在考虑她的女儿。她不想……你知道的，我猜她认为理查德很可能会继续统治下去。我的意思是，她试图两面下注，你知道的，她与玛格丽特·博福特达成妥协，试图接触日后将成为国王的亨利七世，以便他能娶她的女儿伊丽莎白，随着时间的推移，这当然正是发生的事情。嗯，但她也某种程度上在说，你知道的，我的命运会怎样？在理查德的统治下，我其他孩子的命运会怎样？
Well, it's quite clear that a lot of people think that. I think it's quite clear that by that point, most people think that the princes are dead because the anti-Ricardian forces have moved their focus to Henry Tudor, which they wouldn't have done otherwise. And you're starting, so the rumours that Thomas More picks up on and which then ultimately feed into Shakespeare's play, which are, you know, they're originating in this period.
好吧，很明显很多人都是这么想的。我认为很明显，到那个时候，大多数人都认为王子们已经死了，因为反理查德势力已经将他们的重心转移到了亨利·都铎身上，否则他们不会这么做。你开始听到，托马斯·莫尔收集到的谣言，最终融入了莎士比亚的戏剧中，你知道的，它们起源于这一时期。
And they are that Brackenbury, who's the Constable of the Tower of London, has refused to kill the princes. That it's been done by a guy called Sir James Tyrrell, who is played in the Ian McKellen film by Adrian Dunbar. All right, very good. So Ted Hastings. Head of AC12.
它们是：伦敦塔治安官布拉肯伯里拒绝杀死王子们；这件事是由一个叫詹姆士·蒂勒尔爵士的人干的，他在伊恩·麦克莱恩的电影中由阿德里安·邓巴饰演。好的，非常好。也就是泰德·黑斯廷斯。AC12 的负责人。
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Bent copper goes in and does it. And they're smothered by pillows, so that's the story that Thomas More will pick up. Or they're poisoned. Or, interestingly, they're drowned in a butter marmsy. Again?
对，没错。没错。腐败警察进去把它干了。他们被枕头闷死，这就是托马斯·莫尔后来听到的故事。或者他们被毒死了。或者，有趣的是，他们被淹死在玛姆塞甜酒桶里。又来了？
I'm original. Yeah, they're not going to do that again. I'm original, doesn't it? So I guess what all those rumours suggest is that people don't actually know what's happened, which is, of course, what you'd expect. What is strange, though, and interesting, Tom, is that Henry VII, when he finally defeats Richard at the Battle of Bosworth, he doesn't really make a huge deal about the princes, does he?
我是原创的。对，他们不会再那样做了。我是原创的，不是吗？所以我想所有这些谣言表明的是，人们实际上并不知道发生了什么，当然，这也是你所预料的。不过，奇怪且有趣的是，汤姆，当亨利七世最终在博斯沃思战役中击败理查德时，他并没有对王子们大做文章，不是吗？
Well, he doesn't want to, does he? Because he's... He's worried about his claim. Yeah, he's worried about his claim. So, you know, he's going to marry their sister and that's going to be... You know, by that point, he... So initially he's kind of adopted as the Yorkist candidate,
嗯，他不想，对吧？因为他……他担心自己的王位继承权。是的，他担心自己的王位继承权。所以，你知道的，他要娶他们的姐姐，这将是……你知道的，到那个时候，他……所以最初他有点被当作约克王朝的候选人，
but he doesn't want to rule as a Yorkist candidate. Yeah. He wants to park the whole issue. So everything is focused on saying Richard III was evil. He was a dog, all that kind of stuff. Stick a knife in his bare buttock when he's dead, all that kind of thing. But everybody has an interest in letting dead princes lie.
但他不想以约克王朝候选人的身份统治。是的。他想把整个问题搁置一旁。所以一切的重点都在于说理查德三世是邪恶的。他像条狗一样，诸如此类的话。在他死后往他的光屁股上插刀，诸如此类的事情。但每个人都有让死去的王子们入土为安的利益。
And I think that that's the issue. And I think the conc apps you know the the pretty the conclusive proof that henry vii didn't you know the henry vii didn't murder them is that in due course when you start to get pretenders right well this is the thing they don't lie he's in a genuine panic i mean he you know he i thought they were dead yeah well so what's really interesting about this is they don't disappear. Now, you have a parallel, actually. So people who know about Russian history will know that after Ivan the Terrible, there was something called the Time of Troubles.
我认为这就是问题所在。我认为那些确凿的证据，你知道的，证明亨利七世没有谋杀他们的确凿证据是，随着时间的推移，当你开始看到伪王出现时，好吧，这就是问题所在，他们没有说谎，他处于真正的恐慌之中。我的意思是，你知道的，他……我以为他们已经死了。是的，所以关于这一点非常有趣的是，他们并没有消失。现在，实际上你有一个相似的例子。所以了解俄罗斯历史的人会知道，在伊凡雷帝之后，有一段时期被称为“混乱时期”。
And there were all these people called false Dimitris. Dimitri was the youngest son of Ivan the Terrible who had died. And one of the false Dimitris, one of these pretenders, actually ends up ruling Russia for a couple of years or a year or so. So imposter pretenders are very common in history, especially at times of uncertainty and instability. And Henry Tudor is very unstable. I mean, no one knows that Henry Tudor is going to last a long time, do they?
有所有这些被称为“假德米特里”的人。德米特里是伊凡雷帝最小的儿子，他已经去世了。其中一个假德米特里，也就是这些冒名顶替者之一，实际上最终统治了俄罗斯几年或一年左右。所以冒名顶替者在历史上非常常见，特别是在不确定和不稳定的时期。而亨利·都铎的统治非常不稳定。我的意思是，没有人知道亨利·都铎能维持很长时间，对吧？
And actually, the Wars of the Roses don't really end in 1485. No, they carry on. I mean, first of all, just two years after he's taken power, you get Lambert Simnel. Now, Lambert Simnel, bizarrely, is not impersonating one of the princes in the tower. He's impersonating the son of Clarence, who is, what is he, the Earl of Warwick, the young Earl of Warwick. And there's a battle at Stoke Field with Lambert Simnel's forces.
事实上，玫瑰战争在 1485 年并没有真正结束。不，它们还在继续。我的意思是，首先，在他夺权仅仅两年后，你迎来了兰伯特·西姆内尔。现在，怪异的是，兰伯特·西姆内尔假冒的不是塔中的王子。他假冒的是克拉伦斯的儿子，他是什么人，沃里克伯爵，年轻的沃里克伯爵。斯托克菲尔德战役中，兰伯特·西姆内尔的军队与对方交战。
I mean, he's only 10, but the force is representing him, which is actually bigger than the Battle of Bosworth. Yeah. But it's completely unknown because the result is not. So there's him and then there's Perkin Warbeck. And what's kind of interesting is that originally Lambert Simnel claimed to be Richard of Shrewsbury and then changed his mind and became the Earl of Warwick. Yes. And with Perkin Warbeck, it was the other way round. He claimed to be the Earl of Warwick
我的意思是，他只有 10 岁，但代表他的军队实际上比博斯沃思战役还要大。是的。但它完全默默无闻，因为结果并非如此。所以有他，然后是珀金·沃贝克。有趣的是，最初兰伯特·西姆内尔自称是什鲁斯伯里的理查德，后来改变了主意，成了沃里克伯爵。是的。而对于珀金·沃贝克来说，情况正好相反。他自称是沃里克伯爵
and then claimed to be Richard. And he was basically sponsored by Margaret of Burgundy, so Edward IV's sister. And he's a Belgian, isn't he, Perkin Warbeck? He's one of the world's famous Belgians. Yes. Or was he? Or was he? Well, no one really knows.
然后又自称是理查德。他基本上是由勃艮第的玛格丽特（即爱德华四世的妹妹）资助的。他是个比利时人，对吧，珀金·沃贝克？他是世界上著名的比利时人之一。是的。或者他是吗？或者他是吗？嗯，没有人真正知道。
Some people think he came from a place called Tournay. And, um, but it's so unclear. But Horace Walpole and Philippa Gregory, they think he is. They both thought he really was Richard of Shrewsbury, which if he was, it was you know, sad fate. Well, I mean, sad fate for Perkin Warbeck as well.
有些人认为他来自一个叫图尔奈的地方。而且，嗯，这太不清楚了。但贺拉斯·沃波尔和菲利帕·格雷戈里，他们认为他是。他们俩都认为他真的是什鲁斯伯里的理查德，如果他是的话，你知道的，这是一个悲惨的命运。好吧，我的意思是，这对珀金·沃贝克来说也是一个悲惨的命运。
He wasn't very successful uh he he tried to land at deal couldn't manage that got beaten off went to ireland went to scotland uh gave up tried again landed in cornwall ran away got captured yeah got looked after about two years and then got hanged but then he he is executed with the little Earl of Warwick, the younger Earl of Warwick, Edward Earl of Warwick, isn't he? So they're either impersonating him or they're being executed alongside him. It's all very confusing.
他并不是很成功。嗯，他试图在迪尔登陆，没能成功，被击退了，去了爱尔兰，去了苏格兰，放弃了，又试了一次，在康沃尔登陆，逃跑了，被抓了，嗯，被照顾了大约两年，然后被绞死了。但随后他与小沃里克伯爵（年轻的沃里克伯爵，爱德华·沃里克伯爵）一起被处决了，不是吗？所以他们要么是在假冒他，要么就是和他一起被处决。这一切都非常混乱。
So that's all great. I mean, lots of great novels and dramas and whodunits around that theme. But then in 1674, there seems to be an answer to the mystery, doesn't there? So we've got a question from Dr. Sushma Jansari, a very distinguished curator at the British Museum,
所以这都很棒。我的意思是，围绕这个主题有许多伟大的小说、戏剧和侦探故事。但随后在 1674 年，这个谜团似乎有了答案，不是吗？所以我们有一个来自大英博物馆杰出策展人苏什玛·詹萨里博士的问题，
who I hope will be coming on the show, who asks, what's with the bodies of children found in the tower? Have I preempted you? No, that's exactly it. 1674, some bodies are found, some bones are found, and they're identified as the two boys, and Charles IIi orders them buried in westminster abbey doesn't he and he says that yeah he says he'll either relics of edward v king of england and richard duke of york but i think is the general consensus now that they're probably not um well they got they got
我希望她能来到节目中，她问：在塔里发现的儿童尸体是怎么回事？我是不是抢先问了你？不，完全是这样。1674年，发现了一些尸体，一些骨头被找到，它们被确认为那两个男孩，查理二世下令将他们埋葬在威斯敏斯特教堂，不是吗？他说那是——是的，他说他是英格兰国王爱德华五世和约克公爵理查德的遗物，但我想现在大家的共识是它们可能不是——嗯，它们被
looked they got re-examined in 1933 and they're incomplete skeletons and there's quite a lot of animal bones yeah so so again this goes back to that thing about the tower the tower is this big sprawling complex at the time yeah there's lots of different buildings there's probably a lot of different people buried in the grounds um there's no reason to believe that these are necessarily the princes and i think the queen has refused permission for them to be. Well, more tantalizingly, did you know about the discovery at St. George's Chapel in Windsor? Oh, I did see something about this. Which is really intriguing.
查看了，它们在 1933 年被重新检查过，它们是不完整的骨骼，而且里面有很多动物骨骼。是的。所以这又回到了关于塔的那件事，塔在当时是一个庞大、漫无边际的建筑群，是的，那里有很多不同的建筑，地下可能埋葬了很多人，没有理由相信这些一定就是那些王子，而且我认为女王已经拒绝批准对它们进行……。好吧，更诱人的是，你知道在温莎圣乔治礼拜堂的发现吗？哦，我确实看到过关于这个的报道。这真的非常引人入胜。
So there were workmen working there. And that's where Edward IV and then in due course Elizabeth Woodville have been buried together. And they kind of, they accidentally knocked through into the threw into the crypt and they find that there's another adjacent crypt. And there are the bodies of two children in it. And the names on the coffins are two of Edward the fourth's children who had pre-deceased him, but they had,
所以那里当时有工人在施工。那是爱德华四世以及后来的伊丽莎白·伍德维尔被合葬的地方。他们不知怎么的，不小心凿穿了地穴，发现旁边还有另一个相邻的地穴。里面有两具儿童的尸体。棺材上的名字是爱德华四世的两个在世前就夭折的孩子，但他们
they'd been buried elsewhere. Yes. I would see that. Thatased him. But they'd been buried elsewhere. Yes, I see that. That's mysterious. But Thomas, they're not an even more exciting possibility, as recently featured in Her Majesty's Daily Telegraph. Indeed. I don't know whether people saw this. This is, again, part of Philippa Langley's lifelong project
被埋在别的地方了。是的。我看到了。夭折了。但他们被埋在别的地方了。是的，我看到了。这很神秘。但是，托马斯，还有一个更令人兴奋的可能性，最近在女王陛下的《每日电讯报》上登出来了。确实。我不知道人们是否看到了这个。这又是菲利帕·兰利毕生项目的一部分，
to prove that Richard III was innocent. So to be fair to her, she did find the body of Richard III under the car park. So she has form. She does have form. And she is a keen supporter of something called,
旨在证明理查德三世是无辜的。所以公平地说，她确实在停车场地下找到了理查德三世的尸体。所以她是有前科的。她确实有前科。她是一个名为……的项目的热心支持者。
according to Telegraph, the Missing Princes Project, which is led by someone called John Dyke uh and telegraph reports him as saying the idea of a missing prince lying low in devon might appear fanciful at first with all the secret symbols and clues it sounds somewhat like the da vinci code but the discoveries inside this church in the middle of nowhere that's in the middle of dartmoor end of a lane are extraordinary the evidence suggests that edward was so that's edward the fifth so the elder of nowhere, so that's in the middle of Dartmoor, end of a lane, are extraordinary. The evidence suggests that Edward was, so that's Edward V, so the elder of the princes.
根据《电讯报》的报道，“失踪王子项目”由一个叫约翰·戴克的人领导，电讯报报道他说：“一个失踪的王子低调隐居在德文郡的想法起初可能显得异想天开，里面充满了秘密符号和线索，听起来有点像《达芬奇密码》，但这个位于荒郊野岭、一条小路尽头的教堂内部的发现是非同寻常的。证据表明，爱德华——也就是爱德华五世，也就是年长的王子。”荒郊野岭的教堂，也就是在达特穆尔的正中央、一条小路的尽头，这些发现是非同寻常的。证据表明，爱德华——也就是爱德华五世，也就是年长的王子。
And it's interesting, I think, Dominic, that all the pretenders, none of them are Edward V. They're all kind of Richard. Well, probably because he was too well known at the age of 12. So you can't impersonate him. So the evidence suggests that Edward was actually sent to live out his days on his half-brother's land as long as he kept quiet as part of a deal reached between his mother and Richard III and later with Henry Tudor. Once you take all the clues together, it does appear that the story of the princes in the tower may need to be rewritten. Well, you know what he called himself, according to this?
而且我认为，多米尼克，有趣的是，所有的冒名顶替者中，没有一个是爱德华五世。他们全都是理查德。嗯，可能是因为他在12岁时就已经太出名了。所以你无法冒充他。因此，证据表明，爱德华实际上被送到他异母兄弟的土地上去安度余生，只要他保持低调，作为他母亲与理查德三世以及后来与亨利·都铎达成协议的一部分。一旦你把所有的线索放在一起，似乎塔中王子的故事可能需要被重写。好吧，你知道他根据这个自称叫什么吗？
John Evans. And there's... He built his own chantry, didn't he? At the age of 41. And he put lots of clues to himself. Well, among which, on his tomb, of course, if you look at Evans, what are the first two letters of Evans? E-V.
约翰·埃文斯。而且有……他建了自己的小教堂，不是吗？在41岁的时候。他留下了许多关于自己的线索。嗯，其中，在他的墓碑上，当然，如果你看看埃文斯，埃文斯的前两个字母是什么？E-V。
E-V. Oh, extraordinary. Well, well. Do you believe this, Tom? I'm not entirely convinced. I'm not entirely convinced i i'm not i mean when uh when when um when john dyke says that it sounds somewhat like the da vinci code i think that's i think that's not inaccurate i mean basically let me just address the uh the central implausibility
E-V。哦，太不可思议了。好吧，好吧。你相信这个吗，汤姆？我并不完全信服。我并不完全信服，我——我的意思是，当——当——当约翰·戴克说这听起来有点像《达芬奇密码》时，我认为这——我认为这并非不准确。我的意思是，基本上，让我来谈谈核心的不可信之处。
is it plausible that richard who we know is so hard-nosed and henry the seventh and so two incredibly ruthless men who have a track record of executing their enemies which is why Richard, who we know is so hard-nosed. And Henry VII is equally a bastard. Two incredibly ruthless men who have a track record of executing their enemies, which is why they're able to become king in the first place, that they would agree a deal to allow their biggest rival to go and live under an assumed name on Dartmoor.
理查德（我们知道他非常精明）和亨利·都铎，这两个极其冷酷无情的人，他们有着处决政敌的前科（这就是为什么理查德——我们知道他非常精明，而亨利·都铎同样是个混蛋。这两个极其冷酷无情的人，他们有着处决政敌的前科，这也是他们当初能够成为国王的原因），他们会同意达成一笔交易，允许他们最大的竞争对手化名去达特穆尔生活，这真的合乎情理吗？
And that he then, in his turn... Which would leave lots of clues. Yeah, would never surface and try and recapture the crown, but would build a load of clues into the church. I think that's, you know, I mean, stranger things have happened, but not many. That's all I'll say.
而且他后来，反过来……这会留下很多线索。是的，永远不会浮出水面并试图重新夺回王冠，而是在教堂里建造了一堆线索。我认为这，你知道的，我的意思是，更奇怪的事情都发生过，但不多。这就是我要说的全部。
But, you know, I mean, Philippa Langley, she was right with the car park. She was. She'll be laughing at us one day, Tom, in that channel four documentary proving that edward the fifth they'll play bits of this podcast they were going to montage of our shamed countenances oh dear um anyway uh ping pong on the discord asked why are we still interested in this mystery murder over so many others. That's a very good question. And I think actually it is because there are just,
但是，你知道的，菲利帕·兰利，她在停车场那件事上是对的。她确实是对的。总有一天，汤姆，她会在第四频道的那部纪录片里嘲笑我们，证明爱德华五世……他们会播放这段播客的片段，他们会把我们羞愧的面孔剪辑在一起。哦，天哪。不管怎样，Discord 上的乒乓球网友问：为什么我们对这个谋杀之谜的兴趣超过了其他那么多谜团？这是一个很好的问题。而且我认为实际上这是因为确实有……
a final solution I think isn't, I shouldn't use the word final solution, should I? The kind of conclusive solution is not possible. Yeah, agreed. There's not enough evidence. But there's enough evidence to construct all kinds of various possibilities. Plus, of course, it involves kings and princes.
我认为最终的解决方案不是——我不应该用“最终解决方案”这个词，对吧？那种具有决定性的解决方案是不可能的。是的，同意。证据不够。但有足够的证据来构建各种各样的可能性。另外，当然，它涉及国王和王子。
But also, clearly, there's a romantic element, isn't there, to the last Plantagenet, to Richard III, which encourages Ricardians to find him innocent. So there's this sort of notion, isn't there, that the medieval period comes to a kind of crashing end at the Battle of Bosworth. Plus Henry is kind of a accountant, a grim accountant. Yeah, the age of knights and stuff is gone
但同时，显然也有一个浪漫的成分，不是吗，关于最后的金雀花王朝，关于理查德三世，这鼓励了理查德主义者去证明他是无辜的。所以有这样一种观念，不是吗，中世纪在博斯沃思战役中迎来了某种轰轰烈烈的结局。加上亨利有点像个会计师，一个冷酷的会计师。是的，骑士等等的时代已经一去不复返了，
and it's replaced by, exactly, this sort of miserable penny pincher and then his wail of a son. And that people romanticise the age that went before the Plantagelus. They romanticise Richard, of course, because he's the guy from the north. He's very religious, all of this sort of stuff.
取而代之的是，确切地说，这种悲惨的小气鬼和他那号啕大哭的儿子。人们将金雀花王朝之前的时代浪漫化了。他们将理查德浪漫化了，当然，因为他是来自北方的人。他非常虔诚，诸如此类的事情。
And I think then there becomes this urge to find him innocent and also to think, I would say, to think that you have discovered the key to history and something that the academics haven't spotted and all this sort of stuff. I think, just wondering about this, just thinking it out here, I wonder also if a part of it isn't sublimated hostility to shakespeare i kind of that is i didn't see that
然后我认为就会产生一种冲动，想要证明他是无辜的，并且还认为——我想说的是——认为你已经发现了历史的关键，发现了学者们没有注意到的东西，诸如此类的东西。我想，只是在想这件事，在这里仔细想想，我也在想，其中一部分难道不是对莎士比亚的潜抑敌意吗？我有点——我没料到这个。
coming no well there is actually kind of rather similar stuff around the identity of shakespeare you know was he the earl of oxford or yeah that's whatever that's true so there's a question here um ollie oko again on the um on the discord was shakespeare's reputation slipping circa 1593 and he needed a sycophantic pro tutor play to keep the queen happy and boost his there's a man there's somebody who doesn't like shakespeare yeah so i think i think that this idea that shakespeare is a kind of um he's either uh you know he's a fraud who is taking the credit which probably belongs to an aristocrat or that he's a kind of uh sinister conniving sycophant um it kind of i'm maybe if you had a bad time studying him at school or something it's a way to to kind of elbow him aside i mean i just a hostility to the received wisdom
不，好吧，实际上关于莎士比亚的身份也有类似的情况，你知道的，他是牛津伯爵还是——是的，管他呢，这是真的。所以这里有个问题，嗯，还是Discord上的奥利·奥科：莎士比亚的声誉在1593年前后是不是在下滑，他需要一部谄媚的亲都铎戏剧来让女王高兴并提升他的地位？看，有个人不喜欢莎士比亚。是的，所以我认为——我认为这种认为莎士比亚是一种——要么他是一个——你知道的，一个窃取了可能属于某个贵族的功劳的骗子，要么他是一个——一种——阴险狡猾的奉承者的观点，它有点——也许你在学校里学他的作品时有一段糟糕的经历或者别的什么，这是把她排挤开的一种方式。我的意思是，我只是对既定智慧的一种敌意
in general and sort of the idea i think it's a part of that and i think shakespeare is kind of you know as as the greatest writer yeah there's There's a kind of pleasure in kicking him. I think there's definitely a lot of people who get a lot of pleasure. So in The Daughter of Time, Thomas More is absolutely the villain. You know, you get that in, you know. Hilary Mantel. Yes. She thinks Thomas More is the villain.
总的来说，以及那种想法，我认为这是其中的一部分，而且我认为莎士比亚有点像——作为最伟大的作家，是的。踢他一脚有一种快感。我认为绝对有很多人从中获得了很多快感。所以在《时间的女儿》中，托马斯·莫尔绝对是个恶棍。你知道，你在书中也能看到这一点。希拉里·曼特尔。是的。她认为托马斯·莫尔是个恶棍。
So Thomas More and Shakespeare are both, you know, people who've been so eulogised that there's a kind of seditious pleasure in giving them a kicking. But I do also think that Richard's obviously been unlucky in Shakespeare because it's a brilliant play. The Ian McKellen, have you
所以托马斯·莫尔和莎士比亚都是那种被大加赞赏以至于踢他们一脚会带来一种煽动性快感的人。但我也确实认为理查德在莎士比亚的剧中显然很不走运，因为这是一部精彩绝伦的戏剧。伊恩·麦克莱恩的那个，你看过……
seen the... Yeah, fantastic. Set in sort of World War II type sort of iconography. Yes, it's kind of 1930s. A bit like the production of Beckett that I did at Edinburgh Festival, Tom. Yes, it all becomes fascist. I think there's a kind of way in which you could cast Richard
是的，棒极了。背景设定在二战那种图像风格中。是的，有点像1930年代的风格。有点像我在爱丁堡艺术节上制作的贝克特戏剧，汤姆。是的，一切都变得法西斯化了。我认为你可以把理查德塑造成某种劳尔·卡斯特罗或者，你知道的，某个独裁者的兄弟，或者，你知道的，那些阿萨德家族的人——在政权富有 charisma 的奠基人离去后，必须冷酷无情才能维持政权的人
as a kind of Raul Castro or, you know, the brother of, you know, an autocrat or, you know, one of thoseat one of the Al-Assads someone who after the charismatic founder of the regime has gone has to be ruthless to keep his regime in power
为了让自己继续掌权。吉姆·卡拉翰之于爱德华四世就像哈罗德·威尔逊之于……这是你在寻找的类比吗？这就是我一直在找的类比，我很高兴你把它说出来了。好吧，他就像是肯尼迪之于罗伯特·肯尼迪，我想。我觉得他更严肃。
to keep himself in power Jim Callaghan to Edward IV's Harold Wilson is that the comparison you were looking for? that's the comparison that I was I'm glad that you've provided it well he's Robert Kennedy to JFK, I think. I think he's more serious.
他是那个忠心耿耿、发现自己突然被推到聚光灯下的弟弟。但罗伯特·肯尼迪没有。没有谋杀任何儿童。没有谋杀他的侄子。不，我的意思是，这倒没错。但我们又不能确凿地说理查德做了。不，不。你看，我认为，汤姆，我很同情理查德。但即使
He's the dutiful younger brother who finds himself pushed suddenly into the limelight. But Robert Kennedy didn't. Didn't murder any children. Didn't murder his nephews. No, I mean, that's true. But then we can't conclusively say that Richard did. No, no. You see, I think, Tom, I'm very sympathetic to Richard. But even though
我认为他可能确实杀了塔中的王子，但我认为他当时处在一个非常非常困难的处境中，他正在努力做到最好。当然，杀死你的侄子通常不是最令人钦佩的出路，但我觉得，直白地说，在那个世界里他别无选择。他的选择可能就是继续采取这些血迹斑斑的行动，或者基本上就是输掉这场博弈。但他确实输了这场博弈，而且他不仅为自己输掉了博弈，也为他的整个家族输掉了博弈。是的，约克王朝本该——你知道的，当时有大量的王子和公主，他们本该——你知道的，16世纪本该是约克王朝的时代。而事实并非如此，
i think he probably did kill the princess in the tower i think he's in a really really difficult position and he's trying to make the best of it and of course killing your nephews is not normally the the most admirable way out but i think i think to be brutal about it in that world he had no choice his choice is probably keep taking these kind of blood stained acts but he basically to lose the game but he did lose the game and and he lost the game not just for himself but for him but for his entire family yeah the yorkists should have you know there was a plenitude of sons and daughters they should you know, the 16th century should have been the Yorkist age. And the fact that it wasn't,
理查德本可以做出非常非常不同的决定。有趣的是，如果真的是约克王朝的时代，我的意思是，这是在沉溺于一个巨大的反事实假设中，我知道我们在之前的播客中对反事实假设嗤之以鼻，关于反事实假设的想法，一个稳定的约克王朝政权，一个16世纪中叶的金雀花政权，我认为打破与罗马的裂痕并鼓励新教发展的可能性要小得多，尽管
Richard could have taken very, very different decisions. The interesting thing is that had it been the Yorkist age, I mean, this is indulging in a colossal counterfactual, which I know we've poured scorn on in earlier podcasts, the idea of counterfactuals, but a secure Yorkist regime, a Plantagenet regime in the mid-16th century i would say is much less likely to break with rome and to encourage the growth of protestantism although
这部分是因为亨利八世的不安全感，尽管很明显，嗯，你知道的，拥有不合适的婚姻是爱德华四世能够传给他后代的东西。是的，所以谁知道呢，这是真的，我的意思是，也许，也许他的孙子或某个继承人会成为爱德华八世，一个不同的人。所以我的确——我确实认为理查德是一个悲剧人物，而且不是因为莎士比亚把他塑造成悲剧人物的那种原因。他不是那种彻头彻尾的恶棍，我认为他也许是因为最终无法控制的原因，毁灭了自己、他的家族和他的政权。而且他是个彻底的失败者。尖刻。
it's partly henry viii's insecurity although it's obvious that um you know having unsuitable marriages is is something that edward the fourth is capable of passing on to his descendants yeah so who knows that's true i mean maybe maybe so maybe his grandson or some successor would have been at every the eighth and different guys so i do i do think richard richard is is a tragic figure and and not for the reasons that shakespeare makes him a tragic figure he's not a kind of out and out villain i think he he perhaps for reasons reasons that ultimately he's unable to control, he destroys himself and his family and his regime. And he's a massive loser. Harsh.
他是个杀人犯和失败者。是的，非常尖刻。等播客结束时，我就留你去应付那些理查德主义者的信件了。请把你们的投诉寄给汤姆，不要寄给我。那么在离开之前，你认为是谁谋杀了王子和塔里的其他人？嗯，我认为是理查德干的，但我认为他这么做是对的。这就是区别。但他并不对。
He's a murderer and a loser. Yeah, very harsh. I shall leave you to field the correspondence with the Ricardians when the podcast is over. Please address your complaints to Tom and not to me. So who do you think murdered the Prince and the Tartar on it before we go? Well, I think Richard did it, but I think he was right to do it. That's the difference. But he wasn't right.
他毁了自己的政权。好吧，如果他在博斯沃思赢了，汤姆，如果他在博斯沃思赢了，那就是对的。但他没赢，对吧？他没赢是因为没有人支持他。好吧，他在博斯沃思的时候离胜利很近。我的意思是，这很像——你知道的，这有点像阿斯顿维拉昨晚被淘汰出足总杯，汤姆。
He immolated his regime. Well, if he'd won at Bosworth, though, Tom, if he'd won at Bosworth, it would have been right. He didn't, did he? He didn't because nobody backed him. Well, he was pretty close at Bosworth. I mean, it was very much a, you know, it was a bit like Aston Villa's exit from the FA Cup last night, Tom.
胜负本来很难说。抱歉，我知道这是一个痛处。好。非常感谢。我们回见。我们下次要看什么？铁路。铁路的历史。
It could have gone either way. Sorry, I know that's a sore point. Right. Thank you very much. We will see. What will we see them for next? Railways. History of the Railways.
铁路的起源。非常令人兴奋。在节目中，我想丹·杰克逊可能戴了一顶帽子。他戴了，但当然你看不到。
Beginnings of the Railways. Very exciting. In which Dan Jackson, I believe, may be wearing a hat. He does, but of course you won't be able to see that.
不，但你知道它在那儿。好的，那我们就回头见。非常感谢收听。别忘了多米尼克也认为理查德谋杀了
No, but you'll know that it was there. All right, so we'll see you then. Thanks very much for listening. And don't forget that Dominic also thinks that Richard murdered
塔中的王子。所以请把所有的来信都寄给我们俩。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的沉淀》。想要收听独家番外、提前解锁、
the princess of the tower. So address all correspondence to both of us. Goodbye. Bye-bye. that Richard murdered the princess of the tower. So address all correspondence to both of us. Thanks. Goodbye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access,
无广告收听以及进入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可发表评论。
ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
无广告收听以及访问我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。